can we get a number for this one yeah i
don't know
uh five or nine
barbers
since there's a five right there
well it's started at three or five so
we're gonna but use that first or sure
okay yeah
so does everyone know how to play
playing we'll tell them yeah look at
what i'm doing and then do that
you guys want to make sure you press
that you guys want to make sure you're
on everything out of trouble we're
picking high numbers okay so high dots
you don't want high numbers you want
lots of dots you want lots of dots
that's what i mean yeah
lots of dots lots of dots underneath the
numbers so you see six and eight has the
highest numbers because they're red and
then it's nine five i think four and
then [ __ ]
this board is so big i'm used to playing
the point two yeah
ten
whatever
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah get
the high dot
end over here hi dots i don't go first
times because you got the high dots
oh gosh that's where i was gonna go
yeah you were messing around over there
i was like oh [ __ ] i don't really know
sorry to yourself oh yeah i know i am
saying something
that's weird no i i know no no no i'm
gonna put a riot down we go to the left
yeah space off the number
yeah to the left okay yeah
of course
well the good thing about last is you
get to go twice
[Music]
okay i think i want to go here because
if i go here i can go right there but
someone might go right there but you
guys are [ __ ] so you probably won't
do you want me to go there yeah
we work together okay i'm going here
okay heather's turn
are you like this is my [ __ ] too yeah
yeah i got you all games are mine
the object of this game is to get 10
points
uh we roll dies
and then whatever comes up on the die
you pick up as a resource so you want a
resource that has a lot of probability
of popping up
eights and sixes are red they're the
highest probability and then you can
tell by the dots the dots are how many
times each number gets rolled in a roll
of their if we roll this 36 times eight
gets rolled five times ten gets rolled
three
trees roll three
you're making me fall asleep
that's your fault
where are you
need breaking the sheep
wood okay
[Music]
a place with a lot of dots yeah
yeah that's good
that's only eight dots
oh you're still here
you want to come join civilization or
no isn't that simple civilization
dave says terribly unfortunate i have
nothing else to do but watch this
what's up dude hey hold on mars
whereas you should not go over there and
also either boulder like this letter
okay now build a round
you know you see how everyone has a row
about you like nathan's better [ __ ] it
yeah i trust the wire
yeah okay excellent
god damn i see where i'm [ __ ] but i'm
going to keep myself inside your world
right now bro
oh shiva
go ahead
i don't know what the like against other
people are that's the weird part though
well there's other people and you gotta
figure it out you want to not be against
them or would you own your calcio rogue
after your turn i'm going to tell you
something and it's going to blow your
mind yes but go ahead and go you go next
yeah
after giving me going well i was going
to tell after his time
who's the guy in the middle okay that's
fine i guess the robber and then you go
again buddy it's a robber look at you
oh my god come on look at that
two turns so i'm trying to build the
rules all right there's nothing no
you're just trying to build a settlement
you can put it anywhere anywhere you
want is that purple lake
you don't have to do it you actually
can't do it over there you want to pick
up a spot with a lot of dots so pick a
spot with a lot of dogs that you don't
have
what you have is this so you need wooden
wheat yeah that's good actually
this one yeah
that wasn't my next spot or whatever
yeah why do you even pick a spot out
like this far in advance i'm not even
looking at this stupid board until i
know that i'm picking the next reason
and put another house in the [ __ ]
road yeah yeah where there's a lot of
dots i'm sorry pay attention
they're turning horny i think oh cool
why did you put your robe there
put it
that's not a lot of dots count the dots
like the ones on your impressions like
the one on your forehead
yeah what the hell
yeah
is this with the
the silver guys are the guys that are
like the hipsters of katan they're like
oh my god you guys are listening to
uh you know
what is that band
wow you guys are listening to uh
stop thinking
about pick a spot with a lot of dots
you've got to figure out which resources
you need so you have wood wheat and
rocks so you need clay
you need clay and you need a sheep and
sheep
yes and then you pick up these three so
you pick up brick sheep and wheat oh did
you pick up this card
where was your chicken
where did you live
you pick up a wheat
a wood and a brick and then you hide
them now you don't want other people to
say mars your turn okay what about these
two don't pick them back all right no no
no
the bad choice bad choice mars
slightly better choice
you're doing great oh now bad choice
again oh good
it's such a weird game then you don't
think whatever you go here
okay now it's patrick's turn
i love patrick you've been playing
you win here i'm the vape oh [ __ ] you
know where's you've played this before
so you put another one
and a sheep
what are we even are we in sheep
wait you choked you came here
voluntarily right
i did
voluntarily but i have no idea what's
happening i did not know we were playing
katan i did i didn't know how foreign
so this is a podcast
oh yeah what do you guys think about uh
whatever's happening most recently in
the comedy world well whatever's
happening now it's definitely more
interesting than we've had now number
one
well what happened uh
chris risk
we can't have side cut we gotta have one
conversation
hey did you guys this is the podcast
yeah is that hans dropped out of a roast
with me did it
for
joe rogan
have done the same thing after i yelled
and said if you drop all your
what what's that sentence is this your
first language why are you playing with
us nothing says
because you're all i have honestly
the people in the scene
go some good job and go like
yeah yeah
uh
this guy so go somewhere you probably
would say it's gay
i don't understand this but i mean not
gay but like
not a productive youtuber
you can do not a productive use of your
testosterone you can tell them and they
won't come in
do you [ __ ] have
these are they're comedians they hate
everything right
yes true
yeah
joe we're going to be like why don't you
go elf on
investments
can you go back up the money
chris go back to your couch please
huh no just kidding we love crosstalk
right
yeah chris of course
i like nurse more than i like anyone at
the table
why or just because he's responsible
freeze is the funniest person at this
table which is
the funniest part
well what do you think funny actually
means like how do you quantify a
subdirector of nature
and hbo max tell us anything in comedy
nowadays chris grace is the funniest
person at this table
i think that technically you're
incorrect i think netflix and hulu and
youtube would rather choose
eddie
yeah yeah i think eddie is funnier than
kurds
patrick why don't you think
why would you
i'm like waiting for my turn it's taking
forever
we just gotta relax
but that's about it
thanks yeah so you guys like neighbors
this game [ __ ] sound shut up
dude everything sucks you gotta pick
something
we can't just all live on sixth street
and [ __ ] ourselves like crazy
on your [ __ ] on that [ __ ] good tan
table more understanding than anything
oh my god you have no discipline yeah
he has no honor
i'll certainly austin is turning really
like california down dude
how people are brave
why people contain white people are
ancient celebrating
the same
so it's still handstand
yeah
shut up dude you want to get the ones
with a lot of dots i would go right
there that's really your only spot
you know you want that rock bro
you need sheep
you need
though yeah
i guess so yeah so we're going to wait
till that's done
yeah
i thought i was waiting oh [ __ ] i forgot
to get mine
wait what are you why are you are you
slamming like can we
are you slamming [ __ ]
just because that's how you play okay so
we got the same card there let the games
begin
okay where's mars at what's about
cards
seven
patrick i swear to god
patrick you honestly
yeah they're said by shiva
yes
what the [ __ ] is that can we get rid of
that stool that stool isn't even
supposed to be there
it is it doesn't we don't need that to
yeah we don't need a [ __ ] stool to
hold on to the [ __ ] thing
come on
picture i'm gonna put it right here
because i'm not any of these colors and
i'm gonna
yeah
all right i'm gonna build a road i guess
so you're gonna eat
wood
you're mad because i stole it from here
it's a compliment i think you're a
threat i'm not kind of
cool eleven okay
give me two beans
but what do you think about uh the don't
say gay bill and says
oh you can't believe of course at school
they're limiting teachers and preventing
them from what do they think
11
11
do you have any 11's
[Music]
do you understand that like if you're
so where you're like how where your
settlement is
if you're honest or a number if it's i i
got that if it's rolled you pick that
number up so what color are you green
yeah and you're white
so you don't have any lemons
um
so you can't say gay in florida your
teachers aren't allowed to say gay as
much teachers can say yeah so that that
bill was for the teachers there's a
teacher bill
now for like me
yeah we can go to florida and say again
i got a nine i could be like
nine there's a nine here there's a nine
here it was white nine
grab the sheep grab the stream nine
shoot right there and then a nine right
here
that's that's right brick
and then blue who's blue
only red
so what do you think do you think
teachers should be able to say gay
he's not playing or what bro he's too
drunk teachers are allowed to say like
violence
should we play again because she's
taking a good spot no yeah that's the
point is like yeah it's harder
unless you want to start all the way
over yeah
grab the rest of the cards
she said she's going home so
really yeah
well in that case
it's on youtube
some people just can't hack it in katana
choose you up
fine
all right i got life what's that
it's a brick
there's a question of flashlights do you
guys would you guys use a flashlight
yeah
okay why
you don't have a plugin yeah would you
use a flashlight for what yeah
[ __ ] it seven so you gotta move this and
steal from someone count your cards who
has more than seven none of them
yeah
so
move it on
on a spot and steal from someone
okay i want to steal from you
wait is that okay no okay except for my
[ __ ] just one yeah is that what you put
this one out so i can take that one sure
i don't think this one okay
well i guess
about this game relax
backwards
you don't want to buy anything yeah i
want to buy some buy something i'm going
to buy you're holding your cards
backwards
i'm going to buy some uh what can you
buy and break a road can i make a road
can you a brick road
so i got to put it or what too
woo
i got some wood for him though
and you want to build a settlement
somewhere but a settlement you're green
house and road here you go here
you go here which spot do you think is
better here or here none of those spots
actually i want to give me a doc too
well
you [ __ ] yourself
so really
yes okay i can't like move right here
nope
one
you gotta connect it so you can either
filter the settlement here or here or go
somewhere okay i'll go this way
into the distance no you only built the
really painful right building
yeah you got to connect your road
to one of your yeah okay there you go
that works you're doing great
you want to buy something else
no wait no you're trying to give me for
all i got oh do you want to buy
something you want if you have more than
seven cards then it's
i don't know
well if you can buy something you should
definitely buy it okay but uh can i use
wheat can i can i grow something
look at your building card i don't have
brick
oh this yeah so if you have all those
cards you can build what it says you can
buy oh i can't even i can't even build
it
okay would anyone like to give me sheep
for brick yeah
wow you guys really love brick
let's get to that
quarter brick half a brick break
and i'm on the board
and if you pass the dives that means
your turn is over and that's very
symbolic and very important that you do
that nine again nine again nine
um does anybody want to give me brick
for a show
or wheat yeah
do you want to trade again
or what never mind actually i need two
things
i'm gonna build a road
so you can't say a game in florida
yeah well they're just kind of teachers
can't talk about gays when have they
been saying hey
like the the bill is aimed at like don't
supervise
teachers that are like
so gender is fake and like your pp parts
and your poo poo parts
they don't even really matter it's all
like imaginary exactly man
yeah and they're just like no you can't
i don't know how far that bill goes
through
okay that's funny i guess um but i think
that uh
like
you gotta teach them at some point at
some point you gotta be like we're not
just gonna ignore gay people like it's a
big thing and also like i mean i have
been years i've never yet talked about
gays how old are they they're teenagers
already uh i'm pretty sure they figured
it out well yeah you're not a teacher
exactly and i don't even know how to
approach that anyways like what if i
bring it up and they're like okay i want
to learn more about this is it being my
fault
i don't know what's wrong with that
though i don't i just don't want like if
he if supposedly he's they're born gay
so yeah i mean it's going to happen
either way whether i talk to him
so you want to make it as hard as
possible if they are gay no no i mean
even if or what do you mean like ask
them if they know you're gay or not
no like
shouldn't they learn about gay people
eventually like you don't want them just
to like you stumble into it you know
like
at some point we're gonna be like hey
there was a thing called gay marriage
that was like a big deal and like bush
era or whatever and we legalized it
under obama's teachers can't do it
either
well you know it's like we should talk
about gay people you know we should talk
about them i talk about them all the
time people who have before pickleball
nice well whatever they have
like
or foreign i don't talk about gays it's
weird because like sometimes eddie and
uh shiva will like block each other's
heads
do you guys want to angle your bench
yeah so that sir everybody see me yeah
what are they saying
uh
i wish i was cool enough to wear glasses
and a backwards hat inside a house
you know why something from the store or
in front of a store son storage shrooms
and options
nine again
electric back
bye
do you want to leave your vape with me
[ __ ] you [ __ ] walk in
see ya chris
good luck howdy
are you driving mars
hell yeah chris they're ubering yes
great
why do you know so much about mars's
detail is it because you're about to go
in
are you gonna go look out for each other
that would be wonderful
so bad who wants wheat i need rock i got
too much wait no i don't
what about one wheat brick i grabbed
a rock yeah
somebody rolled a c
two
brick and a wood
i don't have wood two brick for two rock
well no
you are not interested
yeah you shouldn't really think about it
like oh you're bad at it it's just you
just gotta ask
tell me tell me how to think
well i'll tell you how to not insult me
please oh i didn't do that did i yeah
it's on record that you're a bad
negotiator
on the record
10.
oh cool i get a blog
all right so what else is uh
10
10
does anybody
have a brick
i got a brick what you need so anything
you wanna
you wanna trade for a sheet
okay there you go do you know what
you're doing i'm getting the sheep i
don't have to do is anybody in the
people oh what are you trying to build
towards i'm going to build a city dude
on that i'm going to build a road
settlement development oh yeah you're
doing good i feel like the point is just
to make it harder for you three
yeah
win the game because i got winning
that's the game
try to build a settlement uh if you
build another settlement you got another
place where you can get cards from buy a
development cartoon
so these are so-called settlements
so try to buy these
they got to be two away from you
patrick is great at this game
pretty good
[Music]
six
five
six
six let's see what's up
got no [ __ ] brick
good deal
so um what do you think about the texas
comedy scene i mean you're from dallas
so obviously you're biased
towards dallas we're from
austin we don't remember you
um i haven't been out to dallas at all i
uh i know that
it's a good place to start comedy three
really yeah i mean it never used to be
the place that you want to move to for a
comedy career
what about building a start
you get a you get a rock that's like we
gotta rock
make moves that is
i mean yeah you don't want to move to
dallas
no obviously it's a [ __ ]
really i haven't been yet it's actually
unique
it's nice it's not as weird as austin
that's why i like it
jesus he's slow revealed he's just gonna
come over here though right
it's not a jail
well it's just too spread out you
shouldn't design your cities to be like
only traversable by highways i mean
there's some definitely a lot more
things to do here in austin but uh
do you want to buy something you got so
many cars you need to buy something the
people are different
let me get i'm gonna do a road here
this game is definitely an analogy for
my life
why do you need another road save up for
a settlement do you have a wheat and a
sheep no just weed in a sheep yeah
just like build a settlement right here
you could yeah how much what do you want
do you have hold on hold on look at your
card do you have stuff for a settlement
yeah i just can't you just put it down
but you know it's worse to go last
because then
i get to go again
no wait if you can pay for something um
i can pay for
a road
oh no i can't pay for nothing else okay
well you have so many cars i know i have
the same stuff
well you can trade four of one thing in
for one of anything else four of one
thing yeah for one of something yeah
[Laughter]
do you want to do that no
anybody want to trade some rocks
for a sheep
no
that while you were laughing what about
some brick for some rock
break for
[Music]
you just gotta run the game
please don't though that's not the best
way
i'm still trying to figure it out it's
gonna be late in the game that i do it
but it's like it's like a native
american's monopoly
totally uh
native american yeah it's a circle
we're all united
making settlements
do you guys ever visit hawaii
i heard that it's [ __ ] for natives
there it's like modern-day colonial
colonism colonism
i hate modern-day colonisms
hey ladies modern day jismism but would
you like if you got a show in hawaii
would you be like [ __ ] the natives
yeah
yeah
it's like a cool place it's like a
little outpost in the pacific i think
they're nice people you took it all
right you took the jet pack
yeah i did why are you laughing oh you
guys did not drive tonight
i flew that into private
does anybody have a rock like what a
couple minutes yeah
it's like 30. that's right
forward yeah
all right i'm gonna play my night oh
hans is sick
what is the prize
that's what you deserve more damn does
anybody have a rock they want to refer
to me well for what what do you need
real stingy
people actually watch you play this no
four
four i got a four
he's got a four
that will be
she will build something
you have you can get grabbed two wheat
yeah see too wheat and you have a bunch
of cards for surviving
something
i'm bruce messing with the paper towel
these right here
yeah yeah because they spilled a drink
earlier oh my god
help me to clean that up
look at what [ __ ]
they're trying to recycle this [ __ ] what
is it what what
recycle this
turn this into something think about it
okay
jimmy give me powerful
there's a gum oh my god
no
i try to recycle my apartment complex
only has one like super tiny recycling
bin
that's full within a day
it's ridiculous
i mean
in korea they have like seven trash bins
and these waste you know plastic bottle
and you gotta sit there
like [ __ ] do this
in 30 degree korean winters
and they do that because they care about
their community
career yeah
that was awesome
it is pretty awesome and someone said
it's a better way to live your life
i get that yes
that's ridiculous what like singapore
would like the not spitting
oh yeah name like its own
uh yeah can they mine as well because
it's like can you imagine if camels were
like walking around your city just
spinning everywhere
[Music]
do you want to carry some dude spit
around on your shoe all day how long
have you been seven minutes
right oh yeah you move that
whatever you think
points was it which is patrick and huh
so those patrick khan's in tell me how
the [ __ ] up on she's telling me what to
do so you would want to either go here
or wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
that's eddie
you would either wait
look at what color on here oh yeah he
does have the same amount of points so
far patrick so you would want to go
well you have no you would want to go
here or like
here
or here
well if you can find like a little
counter like a plant or a tree
yeah
i mean in texas it doesn't matter but
you got to imagine that you're in
singapore which is a city city state
so what everything is
give me this i'm gonna put it back over
here
i don't know there's that no wait i
don't wait you stole my card
he pulled it i really stole my card you
know game on i just didn't want to lose
the card
and i'll take somebody's uh it's over
here if i take somebody's heart
another one okay wait no you gotta move
it
look at her color she's brown
no he it was already here
oh you moved it
bro why did you move it there if you
want to [ __ ] over heather move it to
where she is
oh she's talking about me
well he wanted to steal from here
winning though
so
at all
please that's so suspicious
exactly yeah
it's very quick with whoever lands on
seven she goes hey let me show you
exactly where to put it i know yeah stop
being a little seven [ __ ]
so this is only has three dots eddie you
wanna just pick a spot with more dots
and more people on it like this spot is
five it's two eight yeah i still
[Music]
pick which one
honestly he had 13 before he stole
someone's card so you only have to give
up six
four five
and you should have okay i gotta eat
right now okay i want to build a
settlement before you return
it close it up
eight you had fourteen you're thirty
thirty
so you should have
seven cards right now you have eight so
give up one more
and now you can build right there so
i've got a sheet heaven
yeah go for it yeah uh
rick
so do you think like if uh
[Music]
what do you what do you guys think about
the whole uh me too movement
stuff good stuff you can't you gotta
build a road first
it was great for women
got to build a road first
it was great for women terrible for
comedy well don't you think
very much
it tended to be a
women had such momentum and they just
wasted it going after louis ck and
johnny depp yeah
yeah i love the amber heard [ __ ] that's
it's crazy to see the other side of the
coin
all right it's nice yeah it's killing it
a little bit yeah who who doesn't need
more of that in their life you can't go
anywhere with that i gotta follow the
road right here yeah there's nothing
they'll hear comfortable
uncomfortable by this right where you
could go yeah
i was like it's probably gonna [ __ ]
so what did you say about the [ __ ]
amber heard oh
yeah i mean
who knew that women could be shitty uh
everyone yeah is this new i like this
transfer
you say you like to train a little bit
it's not just another
sometimes when i go to bed hey
and he says it's bedtime
what did han is anything i mean if i'm
not sleepy you're late hans what is it
i don't know i don't remember honestly
oh five
you
such a [ __ ] and who really cares about
her what do you want you want a sheep
yeah no regrets
i want a brick i got a brick for you for
some ride
i'll do that
do it
hey um but no uh he said when she said
it was time for bed and he wasn't tired
that
that wasn't an option that he would have
to lay in bed looking at the ceiling bro
that's a child or amber amber yeah
he said he was 50 something years old
couldn't you know she went to go to bed
on time or whenever he felt like it well
we all needed someone to tell us when to
go to bed because it's like 4 00 a.m and
we're playing katana oh yeah three
but
johnny depp
said that it's time to go to bed i want
you to come to bed with me
like that's kind of annoying and stupid
and petty but it's not a criminal case
no amber it was down here but
every time she said it's bedtime he has
to go later did you roll
like like he said something
not tired
and everything you want you've got and
so like now i want this why can't i have
this yeah
no
this is the first time people okay that
one ah johnny depp i remember i said hey
it's bedtime and you're like
he said i'm not tired i want to watch
some tv and she'll look at him like i
said his bedtime you know what i mean i
said it's bad i said his [ __ ] it's
different if it's a woman though yeah he
said he has to go lay down and stare at
the ceiling this is this is the real
thing that he said
yeah i mean you shouldn't be able to
control people like that i think we have
this idea that people are like you know
one person has to take charge and
another person has to follow but we
should all respect each other's autonomy
and like someone else you don't control
them at all it's just like if you want
to spend time with me that's great in
korea though dude like we we all we
confirm that's what they do in korea no
they do that in korea you dumb yes
yeah they do it in shiva language india
they teach us about grace my school i
don't know nothing about korea yeah i
mean i think it's just we're so used to
bosses
and like uh corporals and generals or
whatever right or like uh
yeah someone taking orders yeah don't
ask no question don't have don't tell
me yeah we think we have like this
hierarchical society and we just think
that you can boss each other around and
then when we have like relationships it
[ __ ] it all up because then we're like
we try to take our shitty way of looking
at the world
and using it in
society
uh [ __ ] dude three two three three
i would say heather is a big threat no
what color are you you're orange no i
mean no that's what we're getting look
at your life right here right here put
it right here right here
and steal it from one of these three
they're all beating you they're losing
everybody
this this is safe from heather heather
what do you think about someone telling
you to go to bed as a grown man if
you're
kind of hot i mean if it wasn't
i mean
come lay
he's already tired he's bored of that
sleep schedule like i'm cool
but i mean honestly i think that's kind
of shitty it's just it's just like it's
like he's
bringing to light all this stupid [ __ ]
that should be like unsaid in a
relationship and he's like putting it
out for like the public
well she she started yeah she shot she
shot first i have no idea what's
happening with the whole case honestly
okay any anything else
she didn't drop her it wasn't ladies and
gentlemen
what happened
what happened
what happened
yeah i'd be allowed to do that what
happened was they had a very shitty
relationship
both of them were toxic they shouldn't
have been together at all they should
have broken
and then they bring out the [ __ ] up and
somebody else was here
but what [ __ ] up
sources from the bank oh
yeah
but what happened was once they broke up
amber heard
that
amber heard went to the public and said
that johnny beat her
yeah
that's where it's [ __ ] up is that she
accused him of being an impact it's a
liberal case when he's like he's
respected his livelihood no one will
hire yeah he got excited for whatever
yeah he's a millionaire
which is like fun
you're allowed to do whatever you want
billionaires
like they were in a toxic relationship
yeah if they were in a toxic
relationship and like whatever like okay
that sucks for both of you but the fact
that afterwards she went after him like
hey he abused me
and she acts like yes the victim a
hundred percent and yeah
she's the [ __ ] second i mean the fact
that john watts john jack
johnny is having her
man
the real thing
why is
the real thing that i've noticed is it's
[ __ ] hilarious that we're all up
paying attention to this johnny depp
amber hurst case
while the just lane maxwell case is
happening at the same time really well
don't be an attention police they're
just saying should be paying attention
this is what we pay attention to at the
same time this is it's inherently more
interesting hey well guys it's like all
of us were like hey we want to know if
we have some matrix if he has to make a
conscious effort what to pay attention
to or what to be interested in it's not
interesting well the
just saying maxwell case is like a
higher trial
so i don't i don't know what it's called
higher
the board is sacred
the board is a symbolic thing
moment of silence for my role
well what were you saying patrick about
your
whatever
boston trials
i was silent oh my god heather
seriously i felt
aggressive it's concerning we're all
willing to take part in yours everybody
what
yeah the longer you do it the funnier it
gets
god damn it you bear stress hell yeah
let me take something from you no you
just thought you're sexy a normal person
never knows my amber hurt
i can tell
she's amber hurting you right now dude
you're riding me right now you're being
a real girl
she's too loud to be jada
i've only showed more jada
eight
eight baby i'm [ __ ] killing this game
right now
thank you
i know does anybody else did anybody
have a brick no what you're telling me i
still have break from her now
i don't want to need to wait for a brick
do i want week
do i want to eat
you want a brick i'll take a wheat
for know what i got everything i need
but i'm sorry
you know what
you started to build something yeah i'll
give you a ride i'm an adult baby
patrick
okay
wait
what are they saying i'm asking for my
tits all right no i'm sticking together
wait
isn't that illegal where did all my
cards go did i just drop them you
dropped them like the die that you
dropped
the fat guy in the back is a fairy tale
what the [ __ ] is
jesus right now not like if he was
johnny depp's or turner yeah
little tug heading style
that's how the game works
you see how it works
[Music]
right
both as if you had just built them did
you just buy that right no i'm gonna do
it
tried to read oh i had another one yeah
when did you buy that one i bought them
at the same time okay you can use one
per turn you were given two resources
which one do you want to use you're
you're plenty or you're you know what
one
yeah well
place it in front of you
place up like you did it proudly
oh is there a lag to this good job
yeah there's always a lag
we're not in the future yet
if you get the longest road you get two
points
yeah
but you don't have to
and now you can buy stuff i am gonna buy
what do you think about the uh
ask a that's a good question
what do you think about russia invading
ukraine oh my god i said ask a good
question you don't like current events
what do you like to talk about that's
stuff let's talk about hannah montana
why don't i rip an eye i
what every comment is about me being
[ __ ] [ __ ] fat that guy because
you're [ __ ] high jackie it's like yo
this fat is another way you want after
crying my bad it's just my
and it turns out it's all about you
because they're selfish what the [ __ ]
bang
what the [ __ ] going on dude
sick are you pro-russian what the [ __ ]
no i am from russia because i don't know
patrick city ukrainian patrick shut the
[ __ ] up
any ukrainians i don't know anything
about ukraine it's not oh i bet you
that's how you thought about the mexican
kids in cadenas
but ukrainians he's like wait a second
we're just supposed to take your side i
don't know anything about you
that's here
let's play now
patrick's the man he's awesome i agree
that's what everyone says
patrick patrick's patrick can you find a
medium between not talking at all
and talking like what you just did
value
anyway hans is mad at me
i'm mad at everyone i stop
my god
[Music]
take your shirt off from flex i might
dude
take your shirt off and flex tomorrow
patrick
all right anybody want to trade me for a
week
what you want
foreign
all right well [ __ ] you then
jesus i'm gonna trade in three feet per
week
and then i'm going to
buy development
i'm barely winning at all
so exaggerated
eleven
oh
[ __ ] yeah you're doing great
so what do you think about ukraine and
russia
ever since i've been born we've been in
either so many wars this this is them
like you know that was your return to
them have their time does anybody have a
wood figure it out i got a little what
you need
uh well uh i'm gonna do i'll give you a
brick
you wanna break from wood yeah
all right it already happened
what do i need what am i going for again
this is an analogy for my life
just like oh it's my turn oh i guess i
can buy this now yeah
i thought it was in storage wars
supposed to buy something oh god this is
on you
i kind of wanted that
wait what did you wrote
doesn't matter
11.
oh i already got it got four points this
loser
sorry man he's got four points
sir what do you have fans dude man
something here's the lowest lowest of
the level what are you talking about you
talk [ __ ] about it
you [ __ ] lose
guy who's below all of my favorites
heather brown
yeah is who's the fan of you
my mom the angry vlogger
you're dead
no you're a great comic patrick
thank those
do you even care hans yeah like i do you
insult me and i compliment you like i
was like
the other day i was like huh so good
night that never stuck me in people guys
like you and me are like the very most
mean you're like mean but you're like
jovial and bouncy about it yeah i'm just
mean and like a skinny guy kind of way
you're here
you're not in an autistic way
it's
don't say that again
none
how many cards you have on a lot yeah
you're supposed to buy something i
thought you were supposed to give
i always spoke about how to say that
i've had 11. it was a calculated risk
all right here we go i'm going to take
it
they're having orgasms over there
people in the chat are funny it's not
because they're mean
but what they're saying is [ __ ]
[ __ ] good exactly
unfortunately
more cards look i only have one there's
just stealing from her
the flashlight
i only have two
houses
i only have two steal from me [ __ ]
can we just have a conversation with one
take two resources from the bank yeah
you can just do it to your hand yeah
so totally just do that right now right
just do it
so what do you think about it do you
think that we should be giving more
support to ukraine
or
russia's
my parents right now but i have a lot
fun to say
about this
yeah you're allowed to say you're not
very excited no but
as a person as the person that
yeah but isn't it
the fault of the economy
what's your availability
i mean the dictator wants to like
do like he's been in power for like 20
30 years right yeah but why is he in
power no it wouldn't have created a
situation where people the people
stop responding to the chat dude
it's so [ __ ] what is it why ever
you're talking to them and not us and
you're ruining this
instead of making this look great
like who do you like better snoop dogg
or martha stewart that's better
topic here's a quick here's a great
question what's your go-to gas station
snack i don't know what's up
malaysia
i'm saying like
no music well i'm trying to say
something that it'll be fun and maybe
cool to maybe not just
talk about what makes our like shitty
emotions jingle
bells is that 12 12 what does that mean
it's like the golden snitch oh yeah
right here so that's how do i get wheat
i mean i just get one or two
down [ __ ]
you do something dude i want sprick
i'll take a brick i
need this man
the reason putin exists is because of us
we create the world
and russian people want putin in charge
because we're [ __ ] them over that's
super cool
yeah
yeah so they have soon and then he
invades ukraine like super sick what's
your gas station yeah we shouldn't snack
whenever i go to the gas station i look
for teddy grahams and i never buy it i
like eggs
like that
no not my gas for me yeah why don't
what what's your favorite gas station
snack all of them dude
and then
steak and then on to reject and then the
buffalo one and then
the green one
on camera are you looking at an olive
okay jalapeno and cream cheese all the
taquitos and then the chili cheese dog
okay i've seen so many beetles
yeah it's like a whole little thing it's
like a little ecosystem over there what
do you think
putin's favorite guessing stone okay
don't trigger heather she's gonna get so
mad
i will
i'll get pissed
i think
like gummy bears or something like he's
probably like a freak
yeah yes i want to know this about you
what's your by all means what's your top
five
shows
top black tv show
breaking bad five times
[Music]
terrible um
yeah patrick why don't we just [ __ ] on
everybody get number four
god what what shows exist what are these
rick and morty yeah i love her oh no
don't even conclusion
you hate everything the cartoon breaking
bad that's terrible
he came here
oh there's a show on netflix called my
first errand or like
that
little children going on errands that's
his fifth yeah in your mind five no
malcolm
logo yeah curb your enthusiasm
oh my god it's like she's a real person
against
yelling
and then amazing world of gumball
it's like she's a real person or
something
whose turn is it it's mine does anybody
have a wood
no i don't have any wood talking about
nobody has wood i'll give you anything
so what is this that you like to take
from tv shows like what is it that
you're interested i love
nobody i love
just uh cartoons like clarence i think
everything cartoon network has ever made
is so good
even the new teen titans which people
argue with me about but the new teen
titans different is different from the
oldest okay what do you think
is what is
how do you watch teen titans like but my
name is download an app for my thing
from uh early ages i've always wanted to
work for cartoon network which i don't
think i'll ever get the longest road by
the way but
i'm sure three four five six i think
everything that cartoon network makes is
great
even though the
cowardly dog or whatever curse
the cowardly dog is [ __ ] that's what
i do
you talk about like a dog swim
you've never had whatever adult swim
success yeah i'm getting there
but yeah i mean tv shows are great i
like tv show do you like cartoons thank
you vlog i mean what do you like
rick and morty
isn't that it you only like rick and
morty shows that that tv shows
like it's not it's morning
culture is salvation
i drink [ __ ] because we're a [ __ ]
culture we don't deserve good subject
i'm i'm not saying that morty's great
and
i'm like yeah i'm saying like
the cartoons made for like eight to
twelve-year-olds are i mean
you got four
fine what they're making now is like
okay
yeah i don't know the version now i
don't let my kids watch now it's like
patrick stop reading the comments
look you got a three right here you [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah my kid i don't remember
kissing myself
i'm not worth the [ __ ] you're the yeah
you gotta just say that
you're done you would what's your fat is
the worst insult if you were then
you fat
you make me way
when you say you fat [ __ ] ago
i'm not worth the [ __ ] yeah
and that's the worst install
yeah you [ __ ] wait i'm joking
well what's up do you do would you watch
a lot of tv at all i love the concept of
tv it's just weird that like
what what is it that you're trying to
get at like
what is the point of the conversation
six
three
of this
i'm saying what do you like to watch on
people i mean you decided to interrupt
us
to ask us about something vague in
general so
thing ukraine all those things
would you rather be lost at c
with two this is what white people talk
about um would you rather be lost to c
ready with yeah this is pointless okay
i'm not going anywhere okay unless you
want to go right here
yeah i was trying to go around and own
this hole
okay
you know i can't do that i mean go here
go get for resources go for it
everyone ignored the call
no one cared about the question would
you rather be lost
or a skin board what's a skin board like
a paddle like a swimming board yeah
uh this
thing that leonardo dicaprio they didn't
play you know um yeah the skin blower
a quarter of them
he's just practicing it's bloody kicked
the skin board you have to like continue
do you want to control his conversation
hans i feel like you're being hostile
right now yeah i thought this is no way
you was really very
current event no we're talking about
cool noodles and you're just reading the
chat
yeah i want to know what okay what's
your favorite movie huh yes
make out with huh
yeah what is what is the point of a
woman
movie is play club yeah you're such a
dork dude what it's a shitty movie
it strikes a tone
i read the book [ __ ] door i read the
book
dark and realistic
oh just to note an emotion back it up
with logic
all right i was forgetting
the words
tyler jordan i wish i'd a narrator
when i had like favorite movies that's
when i had favorite movies when i
enjoyed fight club nine this is the last
kitchen feels like a scene on pump
fiction
pump what move what number number
pump fiction i like medea goes to prison
that's my favorite movie
okay can you can we keep it with 13.
what number did you roll hans that
doesn't matter
fine
uh happiness with nicholas cage that was
a really good movie
okay
i believe you
my favorite movie is uh avengers
right tinsley nightclub nothing human
greatest [ __ ]
give me a better movement
bro give me a better balloon
yeah what you need bro
you gotta give up your cards if you have
more than seven
and i don't
it's very mad
great what's your favorite movie
cannibal the musical my favorite movie
is josie and the
oh what a great conversation i feel like
i'm in kindergarten with you here
wait can they see me you're going to
look at the camera [ __ ]
is that your dev card
shut up
yes
don't worry about oh i already played
that
does anybody have a break
so what do you think about will smith
dude
[ __ ]
hey does anybody oh does anybody have a
building
positive that we can talk about oh no
everything is
that will smith will be heard
four
times
[ __ ] almost killer
[ __ ] are you even look at patrick
patrick's being such a good [ __ ]
he's not being anything
sounds like my ex-wife hey yo
no
that's not that episode
we don't know anything about this person
she's actually a very nice lady she's
poor yeah i'm actually on her side
remember her side
believe all herds
i stand with her
heard i'm surprised that wasn't the hat
yes heather if you're asking if i have
my own channel it's heather keith and i
only have two
videos and one of them is of nobody
one
of me
somebody asked if i have my own channel
it's not good nervous
you know go and do it don't talk about
it oh [ __ ]
move it first but i am the roast
champion of austin texas
self-proclaimed oh road champ
i'm the austin texas first champion of
roast bound you can't take his he's not
on there he's red yeah that's a rogue
you gotta take from this settlement
battles and you'll find two of them
okay you're just
self-aggrandizing at this point
why do you keep asking me here when i'm
drunk dude
you get drunk when you're here you
poured yourself that drink
you did
can i wear your glasses
no
one's definitely not with that energy oh
my god
arms are you mad at me yes
i'm always mad at you
this is the best [ __ ]
i tried to wrote somebody asked if i
could roast on han's
[ __ ] out of one of our ropes i [ __ ] it
out to go to jacksonville though he can
go on at night
with joe my friend joe
open up for joe
again my friend jeff you're not gonna
say doctor
so everybody
don't make a mockery
i'm dating this one would you have done
a roast at the creek in the cave
again
um
anybody want to give me a sheep no for
a wood
give me a brick i'll give you wood give
me a word i'll give you wood for a sheep
heather belt like sheep what is the roll
i rolled off the line
what the [ __ ] is jackson hole
play your stupid card and then i'm going
to move it wait who's green look at
these these are the 3d prints
it's the first time the 3d pieces have
been on
video but it's uh i got
this is the shade 3d printed it's not
shitty
well it's not it's not it's not shitty
it's better than the one at zach
silverman's house
longest road yeah
mention zach silverman again he'll be
really
yeah his dog will bite you
and he has
no cool pieces
that dog is out of control
i know his dog sucks and i hate his dog
so much it's like him
big and powerful and insecure and like
no direction because he has zach's
energy yeah except with teeth yeah yeah
the mind of a dog is so fast you walk in
and he just [ __ ] immediately bit the
back you're like yeah he could sense and
another alpha was in the room is that
nice
not [ __ ] dogs nobody cars [ __ ] dogs
i love [ __ ] dogs
i love you yeah but people like the more
than people people are not
important i don't know all about why are
dogs though
that's my thing
they're [ __ ] they're like on the
ground they can run fast and they're
like a missile
you can tell that they're below you
yeah physically do you want to just tell
us where to move it
why why are you stealing from poor eddie
yeah with so forth
[Music]
from brown eddie
who's green
so what do you think about zach you
think that maybe he should have his dog
euthanized yeah i think all of us
be well i think he's like dogs going no
baby
yeah
with that dog down yeah
dude that dog was after he bit me he was
just like on the couch and they just
staring at me and i was like okay
it's like a siberian it's like a husky
it's like a lab dude no but then you
have to be cool when it is
he hates dylan sullivan
comes in dylan like he barks at dylan he
needs to be the physical alpha that bug
that dog assaults because zach is not
going to spill that rule he knows zach
he knows zach is big but he's not he's
not going to do [ __ ] i don't think dog
needs to pay and then he sets
like dylan sullivan in the room i mean
are you yelling about the dog about cart
like a tan game
i don't know we're here for those on the
board over there dude does anybody have
a wood
dude patrick has seven points now one
two three four five six
one two three four five play after the
six seven
it's
four arms took over the whole board and
it's pissing me off that's good
otherwise the board is pretty big just
did that play with the board you're
giving it
about no no and lance check that drunken
that's
yeah
our world has mars being drunk in it
[Laughter]
why are you wishing for a different
world when this is
the reality when mars is such a
beautiful soul
what's happening
who likes me he [ __ ] likes me right
now you can stay right there where i'm
at patrick what's up tracy
no
put it right there next to it put it on
number eight right patrick's the brown
and we gotta have like a good
conversation so that they can comment on
it we can't just be one of the
challengers
okay open ended questions if you walk
out there keep it going you simply watch
your screen of your favorite movie you
watch the lisa bill documentary no i
didn't oh did you watch okay did you
watch the don daisy no i was probably
busy flying in a private jet okay [ __ ]
relax
john why did you just sit on the couch
watching movies and getting yeah
smoking and community watching movies
yes i don't know it okay
i am not familiar with the dallas comedy
scene
excuse hans what was your favorite band
when you were 12.
uh blink 182 really
tell you about me
what about that
yeah so i'm just gonna say bands and
you're gonna have emotions you should
ask now it's 12 it was flying
when i was 12 it was sincere for brown i
don't have any cards apparently you're
getting mean right yeah
[Music]
okay
182 joke guys keep up yeah but i hold
yourself five cause my old self would be
asking me that right
yeah it's not funny at all
it's just a song what's an excuse to
why are you so well you want to control
the conversation but then you don't have
anything to say okay hans somebody said
in the chat that my favorite band is
meatloaf and i don't
that's his favorite food
other than the one song
what's that one milo song
i can't i'll do anything for love but i
can't do that
[Music]
congratulations oh my god hans you're so
mean to me no you're doing great heather
everyone's back here
say hans it's me
i am mean
i'm mad at you and i'm mean lean in a
little bit you have to get over and i'm
autistic and i just say
awesome surprise i'm just being mean
right now
god damn
what did you think you got to build you
got to replace the settlement
no i don't know
we're literally [ __ ] like
really close
way closer than i am
again you're [ __ ] right
if there's a line go across it that's
one two three four five six seven eight
they're tied okay
do you want to like actually contribute
to the conversation
i would never
here we go what's your favorite band
shiva
some death metal [ __ ]
is some stats
thing it was like 10 years ago
all jays
all joe is good elevator
all jay
pretend someone owns that and they want
to keep it around forever and then don't
just don't use it
let's
hey there's a nicer way of asking me
can you let's try again
okay
okay
first let's admit that you're an [ __ ]
and you're just
crazy
i can be an [ __ ] someday i admit i'm
an [ __ ] sometimes too
that's wow what a great place
maybe you could just
slung a roll
one of your many roles it's it's eight i
i
there's a bag of potato chips
patrick can't help but eat all of it
what's your role
my favorite n-word
neighborly
nostradamus
nasty what do you actually think about
black people
because that's patrick's
what's your favorite n-word joke i said
hans my favorite n-word joke i don't
listen to black comics
whoa guys
i'm in the chat
it's just so like all emotion based and
hey did you watch the chorus
no i have it
it was pretty pg
i'm sure it was yeah i'm sure it was
trevor noah and joe biden and and james
corden
james porter jimmy fallon
and they all sang in their car and it
was beautiful
honestly
i think that black people are some of
the most talented comedians and some of
them are so funny and they
don't get the respect they deserve
because they're black
[Music]
they did a new show right yeah i got it
and you do like uh
does anyone have wood no don't trade
with a mexican
somebody said uh
somebody said i'm starting to like the
mexican again but there are literally
three mexicans
oh three yeah
steve is a mexican from the east is
eastern mexico
yeah they loved it are we gonna have to
wait
i like him
you guys can do whatever the [ __ ] you
want
the same questions
because you're loud you're you demand
detention for no reason
because you need to control the
conversation you know what she missed
are you mad at her yeah
you're emotionally needy
you're a chat obsessed
not not oh that's patrick that's bad you
guys run together
for me and my mind you bleed
i just want to make sure that this is a
good podcast
yeah it's honestly
i'm dumb when they come back
well
people are going to be watching this
all 300 of them
somebody asked us to kiss hans
i can't kiss what are you both kissed
yeah before
i tongue kissed him sorry one time
what are you doing patrick you're just
you always cross the line whatever line
that's all you know how to do try to
like contribute
color within the lines for once
[Music]
so what do you think about
the nature of uh conversation alice
is about to bomb with another question i
agree
what is your question patrick who do you
think
the stanley cup is here
oh
um mr chris guy probably
i want to hear it so dallas is a good
scene yes i haven't been but i heard
austin
yeah i did one open mic there
but there's like hilarious shows like
latrice wilkerson [ __ ] around yeah
i mean even before the pandemic you guys
are a beautiful functioning scene
it's a big city it attracts a lot of
blacks and uh latinos
more than austin i don't know
yeah that's that's the way we like it
yeah i think i got the longest road now
don't i it
maybe
wait
one two three four that's right six
seven eight
yeah you definitely have two wait one
two three four five six seven
nine no green yeah yeah no you do
which means you're at one two three four
five six seven wait one two three four
five six seven eight you're at eight
point jesus
whoa
look who
you're white
getting ready to be put out into use
four
how many more
me that we
i didn't do the blue squeeze joke
the bubbles
[Music]
thank you for noticing
everyone cares only about you
hans calm down can i hit it i never i
never had
come here yeah
you okay come here
you're just you [ __ ] to [ __ ] you
know
[Music]
i'm mad at you just tell her
taco sand or whatever
is heather the girl that went on
pillpony with the blue clue thing
uh
give a [ __ ] i haven't been on kill tony
since so who cares
i got nada for you
why do you hate eddie
dude i've been picking
hate on
well the thing i like about dallas is
that it's a big metropolitan area
and it's not coastal which is uh
did a competition nationwide comedy
competition and supposedly he didn't
even know about it
but they said no he did a competition
approval
either
there was a lot of comics that showed up
and performed on that competition you
need to yeah but i mean there was a lot
of killers bro
well you know there's a there's a guy in
dallas that you had me on the show with
the black guy
this yeah oh yeah he's super funny
yeah and then others who are your
favorites in dallas
for what the trace is
what's the other one you said
no
yeah
isn't it weird that like we rank like
where the funniest comedians are and
like it's not it doesn't really matter
like we're all doing it like everybody's
doing a different thing
it's a weird hierarchy
it was nine and it was nine how was that
you're laughing at your crazy boyfriend
rock that rock created with me without
anyone who's like yeah here yeah but
then a lot of stuff happened between
then and now
like he blamed the thing over and over
again hey homes so i was just trying to
figure out what you were maniacally
laughing at wait one second though
calm down
but yeah i mean dallas is a great scene
but can they really measure up to
measure
can you measure up to casey rocket and
dylan sullivan
dylan's my baby boy i guess
asada mod i love derek sam lopez
sam logan's derek poston are the perfect
comedy couple
i love them so much together
yeah they
yeah
derek doesn't try and he has no chin
he no no he's but he's three oh my god
he's really super [ __ ] funny all he
yeah he has to go up there
yesterday
oh [ __ ] for the game i want to play a
new one one two three four five six
seven eight and you just picked up five
rocks
oh i picked up four but now it's
dignified
yeah i mean
you know texas comedy scene is strong we
got houston uh uh
the [ __ ] great bruin
scene
relate to the new york scene
uh doesn't even compare not even emails
[Music]
tom's a girl who doesn't go out like
ever you know
like aria
like l.a you got a brick ari's new york
all right
um we got [ __ ]
uh what's the fat guy
tim dylan dylan has my house has a house
here he doesn't wait till joe rogan's
club opens up i mean this is definitely
we've been waiting who does chicago have
oh we've been with chicago
we've all been waiting this is
definitely the third city now
i mean i'm talking [ __ ] seems like jay
i'm going to be in chicago maybe
whatever
may whatever
all right nobody got broke right
fine
eight
sure but yeah i mean i love the strength
because we don't need just new york and
la that's an unhealthy ecosystem and
everyone is just up in those two streams
you really changed the game
i think the awesome take over but
everything where everything everything
what it used to be is not the way it
used to be anymore like it really
changed the game and that's a lot even
what people care about like people don't
care about the kardashians not me
whatever
people don't care about the superficial
[ __ ] they want real answers yes they
want their wishes
or whatever
yeah la's fake as [ __ ] new york was like
devastated by the pandemic but it was
real
but they'll come back stronger you know
they're going through a bunch of crime
[ __ ] like new york is too strong is
making our mark and go super up
uh buying these houses over [ __ ]
i rolled an eight like 80
don't care about whether a conversation
is depressing you just don't want to
have it at all like we're talking about
new york and l.a
dumb that's what i was saying like what
you were talking about earlier
try to not what you were talking about
earlier about new york and l.a
i think new york is better
yeah why
is it it's good
goodness
what do you think about austin coming up
like why did you choose to live here i i
moved because all my friends moved down
here i
cannot all your friends
moved to ukraine would you move to
ukraine yeah
no but i
what happened was i started comedy in
new hampshire
and i spent a couple of years and uh
where did you move from new hampshire
oh okay
i spent romp i moved from colorado
no it's an eight that's six no you
rolled an eight you wrote six we all saw
you rolling
the name
no he rolled the name
though it was just a shitty boy or
friend
that's six eight look at it
patrick put back your cards and lose
like a man
all right it's eight try to be a
colonizer that's six what are you
talking about you changed the role no i
did not
okay anyways what were you saying
heather
i was saying that i moved i i started a
comedy in new hampshire
he needs to do it no i started comedy in
new hampshire what were you talking
about why did you make it
why am i talking about my love story
what is the context
for me i'm sure and then i i moved to
colorado because of the pandemic because
i lost my apartment i lost my job where
there's nothing but then my apartment
i'll move to colorado for the pendant
because there's no air there no because
my my parents lived there so i had to
move back into my parents austin got
elongated come down
so i had so i had to move back in with
my parents
and then all of my friends moved to
austin and i was like
guys and now i have a lot of fun i was
like why are you guys moving to austin i
guess i'll follow you guys to austin and
then i
followed them to austin and then after i
was like oh
oh joe rogan moved here oh tony hinch
well you're you're not you're like
you're gonna have you i have no idea who
joe rogan congratulations
don't know people
no um then other than i knew he was in
fear factor i didn't know he went to
media
i yeah i watched star trek network i'm
literally yeah what about chris the
cowardly dog moved here all right and
would you be happy all right
guys
then i was like oh that's cool the
comedy scene is down here i didn't know
that
i don't you fell into the city that
everyone else was moving you didn't even
move here consciously
i wanted to get out other people
was awesome
can we can we i moved here
because i
thought like oh all my friends are
moving there let me
give it a try and then it [ __ ] turned
out to be great oh what do you want
right now i'm [ __ ] each other over
there you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're dallas [ __ ] so you moved here
because your parents were [ __ ] and you
wanted to come here to be with your
friends yeah and then you saw patrick
well because i loved comedy
patrick
and i'm getting sad again
i moved here no i'm sad
but yeah he showed up from new hampshire
because
he had nothing else to do yeah because i
loved comedy i wanted to get back into
comedy but this is an awesome scene the
whole world i totally didn't know
anything about anything
i happened to be in my best friend
for joe rogan yeah i did one though
after it sounds like a joke i love it
when she has a
reaction to things every now and then
he actually flew [ __ ] fortnum
what was happening down here i just
wanted to get out of my situation
and i knew myself parents and i unless
you have them what yeah and i had to
live in a hotel for like a week well
[ __ ] heather's parents.com
yeah subscribe to the newsletter are
they watching so i i
might why did you say it
kicked me out because i didn't wash
literally one dish so they kicked me out
i had to live in a hotel there was a
symbolic thing and then i had to live
with my brother for a while sure you're
not easy to live with and then
sure yeah and then i decided all my
friends are in texas i'll just follow
them there and then i moved down here
and that was without something about as
long as you're moving to texas you
weren't working in that heart hey guys i
need everyone's brick
up
no one likes it yeah nothing everyone's
breaking i got regrets no bricks that's
the bricks yeah i try to get a break
from you you've got the mix dude you
gotta look at the stacks and see which
one is the most full so you can't just
blindly just ask for [ __ ] that you need
all right
yeah you can't just this is that's kind
of heady that's true
once you fired victory yeah you got it
hide it you never show that [ __ ] dude
when will you learn you keep reading
this [ __ ] out loud nobody cares right
now
what so
you're playing a night how many cards
you can only play one development card
at a time okay so i'm just gonna you
already played it
i think longest road night yeah
congrats
it seems like a big deal that one's
happening it's been crisscrossing in
front of you
i want it you're the
longest wishing you had rode
um but yeah i'm glad you're here heather
you're a very yeah funny comedian letter
on other people again you are alex has
the last time i was on your other
people's show no i don't we're not like
this
you're hilarious you're great
yeah you're fantastic
yes i don't mean
wait
two weeks i wouldn't do it again that
would be fun you want to do it this week
sunday
yeah let's do it
yeah that'll be 10.
those three serious i forgot to put the
brick too okay
a lot of fun doing it but last time i
was very drunk you can't put it here
that's the case okay eddie please it's
the case you have 10 points and you win
no you didn't oh wait does he yeah [ __ ]
one two three four five six
one two one five six seven eight nine
ten
he wins
no one cares about all right again
you guys want to play again no oh yeah
over there
mars [ __ ] it up i am
[ __ ] like do you want to sit out so
we can play a four player born
[ __ ]
part of it
okay don't give everybody your stuff
though let's make sure that things that
fall on the floor i picked up he won
okay ready one great
they have to use this
how many development points did you you
even had a one plus one so you had
eleven points let's get to four
okay let's play this again like i'm
pretty sure you're stealing from the
dude's taking
so what fell on the floor yeah that's
not special i think it was one of them
[ __ ]
i feel like i'm doing my people proud
right now
yeah make up for the spanish-american
war or uh
whoever war are we yeah yellow we don't
even name the wars with you
guys did it oops
came from
then
please stop digging through my fridge is
that your dijon pizza though yeah you
want to cook it up can we fire it up
let's get it going yeah i'm hungry
you're always sad
is that your favorite is that your
favorite bag
no no no no
i think i figured this game out now
yeah yeah yeah
hey you figured the game out can i just
say
franz is being mean to me tonight
can we just say that can we all agree
hans be mean
nobody
no they're probably russian bot how many
people are on here oh that um hans being
mean
and i wore the shirt last time i live
streamed
cool all right let's play
how many people are having
everybody in the everybody in the chat
tell me what was your favorite band when
you were 12 years old
no we're not going to put the dessert
down there
huh
tell me
tell me what your favorite band was when
you were 12 years old
hans is being mean thank you
hey you guys drinking now muscles
yeah hans is autistic i don't blame him
i love him
he's sometimes mean to me but i don't
give a [ __ ] because he is autistic i
love him
when he's mean to me i'm like yeah okay
i love you but whatever
he pissed he's done stop
every comedy
watching i don't know if they read the
comments and just read and just hand
people
no not god
not that nothing
not that
not that not that what the [ __ ]
no
only perseverance right yeah
no chris and mars are gone
chris and mars are gone
how are you dumb [ __ ] we gotta get this
going
don't think i'm gonna use that guy's
name each other here right no no we met
in new hampshire
three years ago three years ago we met
each other
and we were in love we were serious
shut up
we literally like started doing stand-up
at the same exact time no
[Music]
almost started three months after me not
really
no
wait no
oh my god somebody else put this game
together i can't do it
ah
i'm gonna pee
holy [ __ ]
well obviously that one guys
how's the new hampshire scene
it was amazing back in the day
back before 2020 it was [ __ ] amazing
but then after 2020 it was just ten it
was just gone yeah
it was weird how dead it was
[ __ ]
oh other
you're so funny you'll just sit with a
tripod like in your face when you don't
have to do that
no i don't it wasn't even my [ __ ]
face
we need to see your sad little faces
what are the [ __ ] knees oh the pod oh
geez these look it's sticking you guys
been smoking all [ __ ] nights yeah you
[ __ ]
animals
well i had some sheep bro hey do you
have any of those uh i still can't
believe you [ __ ] one dude i'm so
pissed about that why did you trade with
it you went no no cause i didn't think
he was gonna win that that's just
[ __ ] you were giving me everything he
was being a steady anyway
you totally got delighted by eddie again
again yeah
we quicker than that yeah who else is
going to build the road
yeah i'm cool with it i ain't building
the road
i don't
oh man i love this
are you from here
i'm from here and lived in new york for
a couple years and then came back
i learned that everywhere was better
than where i was from
it's better or worse look better then
why do you love texas if everywhere is
better uh
we get to say [ __ ] here
yeah you do get to say [ __ ] here
you get to say [ __ ] a lot of people
our team didn't say that
i don't just i don't use the word [ __ ] to
describe like gay stuff but no fact
when like
people like
like my whole life [ __ ] never meant gay
stuff
whatever you meant gay stuff
i did yeah i meant write myself a [ __ ]
dude
i hated homosexuals
i mean it's it's a word
you can't just decide what it means
donate any money donate it to venmo
adult
[Laughter]
[Music]
has a job hans opens up for joe rogan
adult underscore kiddo
feed her addiction 11 at least
again
yeah
off first christmas in the hundred
dollars
do it for you three
eight eight
oh you didn't even put fame on my name
nah if you don't respect him i can't
even take a picture of it tense that i
beat [ __ ]
someone had to be like next damn i think
i think eddie won read that i think
heather was like that means that he wins
he's been taking forever
i guess it's fine
okay who got
who got whatever
let's do it over here we got ten what
did you guys get
you got ten yeah i got a jig i got six
hundred five of me what did you get
okay you go first who does that trick
all right
um
why don't we move it closer to your
father
opt-in
so you don't have to lumber
oh you can't do this wait you can't have
two reds next to each other
it's so great in the lie cheating liar
it's on the right and it's when i lie on
the internet
oh heather five bucks now why um i'm not
your venmo i'm not gonna be doing
clerical work for you guys
find her on your own
or kiddo i
can't pay rent today
whose fault is that
me your poor financial choices
who's paying my rent tomorrow
this isn't a sustainable solution
7-eleven taquitos please those are easy
just three dollars literally
three dollars
it's insane when you go and buy like you
guys
have sleep schedules
where do you guys normally go to sleep
comics have sleeps
because then you're not
way before me oh the lack of discipline
what the [ __ ] sign of degeneracy
blamed yeah it's called defensive
measures
defending yourself we're not actually
friends yeah you attack me and i have to
defend myself it's quite scary actually
that is something you're like
put him down [ __ ]
you won last turn you got no [ __ ]
quarters
oh let me just
[ __ ]
i'm the same card by the way
you're not supposed to do that
so what's your favorite movie
back spot
well five cards
i mean
there's no number here
you only see the board i see
i see the future of the board
we should have won the basket
well
luckily your mexican strategy of just
going doing whatever it worked yeah i
was listening to your favorite movies
while i was playing
i know you were listening to them our
babble
you got to take the shades off you're
like willed poker yeah the first person
to send me a hundred bucks i'll uh take
them off for them what an honor
no i can't wait till you finally take
your shades off again my venmo for that
i'll pull it out you you send heather
keith a hundred dollars i'll pull up my
dick on camera i don't care nobody wants
or nobody knows no the guy in the chat
wants that
yeah
a dude in the chat wants that so what
about what we won
do you feel good
i feel great
when my dick is out i feel like the best
i've ever felt yeah
are you timing the [ __ ] pizza thing
yeah
do you preach though yeah hell
my phone okay
just in your head
it's another pizza clock you know what i
think the comments so can we finally
discuss it comments will tell us when
the pizza is
ukraine and russia bro
do you need uh can we talk about them oh
you didn't even put it in yet
what can we talk about the real issues
russia and ukraine heather do you want a
police our emotional uh
you know we got to keep it at a certain
emotional level for you to be engaged
and you're fine
i'm out of the conversation since you're
mad at me for dictating
all right
do you know any ukrainians yeah you do
give me the first and last name of one
isn't your girlfriend in ukraine i was
seeing a woman who is her man
who is still ukrainian
she's a very beautiful lady
no it's just you don't have the capacity
to give heather five bucks for me smuffa
shaking my [ __ ] head i think that
means
yeah i don't have the capacity
send me more money to watch me not give
it to heather
he just been five bucks
that's some wish why do jerking off to
heather
thank you
wait okay give me one [ __ ] second
we're giving you a lot of seconds calm
down
this isn't the next one
yeah okay so i'll do that and then i'm
sheep rock we so know
wood and
oh because she's
strategizing
yeah she is a kindergarten teacher
oh my god no way it's real oh my god
could you be i don't know
i'll say your kids
yeah what would you teach your
five-year-olds about gay people
that's it
yeah you're [ __ ] a woman
wait give me one second
you're good patrick did you put it in
the oven
yes it's timing by the way i just want
to say i [ __ ] hate that my name isn't
just patrick and in every comment i'm
just the fat guy in the back no one is
talking about you
that bad guy
it's also because of the rolls on your
back
that wasn't fine
of course not
is it my turn no
oh
you went first
so you guys know that's my turn
look at the board wait what are you
talking about because you already have
one of your resources yeah i got to put
two down you're like i never went i
never went first yeah i went first and
it goes all the way and then it goes
back this way remember how katana is
never i i have i'm red i never went
twice yeah you don't go twice until
everyone else goes twice
that's not true i go first i go first
patrick trying so hard it's back around
the other way
what comes over here
when you're not hearing if you're a
person i know
i know i'm right i have been right and
then will ricky marcus says when you're
first 11 yeah
you're fine you're fine you're right
it's fine oh they're still sending five
dollars
but don't know venmo heather i promise
we'll download it tomorrow and send it
oh that sounds like a broadcast dude
i'll probably tomorrow
tomorrow i'll see my venmo whenever i
wake up
yeah he's broke ass dude sending us five
dollars to play katan oh yeah
it's your turn eddie
what heather's typing back we can all
find what heather's been watching on
youtube now
either are you sure you want to put your
troll account up there
oh she down bad heather keaton i'll sell
feet pics or whatever fam
some low-grade
only fans humor
i think it's
funny to sell yourself out like that no
i'll never no my feet are so gross
that's literally just a joke
everyone's feet are gross are they
particularly gross no they're literally
gross i think some girls have really
cute feet mine are size nines and bad
well maybe some like that's beautiful
it's
functional it's practical yeah you could
like [ __ ]
you know
clobber some pose
that's what you know they're bad right
there
you're you're not a do nothing [ __ ]
what do you mean
i mean your body serves a function no
like ronda rousey
who ronda rousey what's that the ufc or
the wwe right you didn't receive it
i have a skit point that's a good one
yeah i mean they're both pretty badass
rowdy rowdy rousey or is it the ufc
got knocked out hey i don't know knocked
out i got russell oh yeah
i think uh who'd you lose to an mma who
would she lose to in ufc it was holly
holm
is i think losing to charlotte flair is
more badass the daughter of ric flair i
think losing to the daughter of ric
flair is more badass than losing time
nobody knows because it's not that much
that's fake no that's a real match
nobody [ __ ] knows who holly holm is
nowadays nobody gives a [ __ ] about holly
holm
that's a real thing that happens
took down a force of nation yes
scarlett flair
sure
was born into a family
respectfully
when it worked her ass
takedown of titan rick fair says woo
charlotte flair says play with that for
no reason what does charlotte flair say
charlotte fletcher
yeah she does of course just his
daughter she has to we don't have to
have it that wives girl narrower
like we've probably was before
just don't play with it how bad
how about if you're
not having like the best
i'm just saying
the other teeth is on here
hey uh hey [ __ ] patrick it's your
turn now is it fine yeah
but it's not showing up correctly guys
what are you laughing at heather
do you see this how the brick is cut off
right here
you got to point it more up
that's what i was trying to do and then
it fell off at this you were fiddling
with it because you're all right all
right let's go go for real
hand me the phone
wait to make sure that it's [ __ ] set
up correctly
that's too much
okay
no a little bit down okay yeah that's
gonna be fine it's fine
perfect
either are you typing
quickly drop it
leave it
[ __ ]
six
patrick it's six
okay why did you roll like that
because the one fell out but why did you
have to slam it around it was my bad
yeah it was your back shut up
now it's
i'm fine
[Laughter]
what are you laughing at what are you
laughing at
um you be nice you're tackling at your
phone on the podcast
eddie was having like a real moment of
greed
nine
oh [ __ ] i didn't pick up my first
settlement
shut up eddie
hell yeah
you're like the face of like greed or
like you should be an emoji actually i
saw him on a face of global watch yeah
i'm stretching burning this
where i put my wars yeah you're earning
it by convincing people you earned it
it's a part of earn i guess hey we got
this all filmed
yeah get more drunk that'll help
three
oh i gotta break myself wow look at the
[ __ ] camera now
you [ __ ] idiot
oh god
right there that's good
anyone even watching
i know how much work i have to put in
get that care going
good things have a lot of work i'm
helping this bug
out
by not trying at all and doing whatever
you want
i'm gonna go for win number two four
wait what was your number
don't worry about it
before
are you mad at me is there a four
there's a four here where's the other
four
four
oh that's there
we'll see you have it
yeah calm down yeah
are you you got you got your wheat
yeah yeah
go ahead
whoa oh no wait what's it doing yeah
let's let patrick do it and you can just
roll
it's not the oh god it's it's not the
tripod leg
it is the six you got to tighten it down
better
god can you please sit down
i'll do it okay i'll
uh what
no
are you sure or what
do you want
i'll be right
yeah that's true now did you do that you
didn't have brick
does anybody have
does anybody have a wheat
and a wood
rot
or i'll give you a weave for a rock
wait for uh
do you want to give me
whatever a wood for a rock
wood for a rock
hans yeah
[Music]
first rocket
break
no i mean for what i'll give you for a
break all right you're gonna make a
brick yeah huh i'll take that i'll give
you another cheaper now no no
all right
i don't like when you say no
yeah you're you're so [ __ ] cool with
the last game
i mean
now you're not talking like it's your
horn is it a pizza burn yes [ __ ]
precious all right bro eddie stop
gaslighting people
not 100 supposed to do that
anybody that brings up gas lighting is
gaslighting right you don't have to
always act the way you look so can i
make it
can i make a
finally got some wood everybody but me
dude
let's take it
all right and then richard
i can me i'll give you breakfast with
that wood
not until my tour turns or your turn you
can't trade until it's your turn or my
turn yeah right i can do that i did that
yeah yeah you're good
love it so do you think amber heard it
shouldn't have told johnny that went to
go to sleep i have no idea i have some
weirdness the
the bed that's normal in mexican society
hey
and then they blame the dogs that's some
white people [ __ ] to be like we're all
going to bed honey
there's a nine what is your role shiva
he rode
oh what about patrick
i rolled a 8.
wow nice
[Music]
she's cute
no that's patrick's lady
what's the brand coheed and coachella or
something that's the band i was trying
to think of earlier like for singing
like in
the date of night
so
what do you think about like amber heard
whose side are you on heather
johnny depp or amber johnny depp yeah
what about you which is hard because
like i
being someone who has been in an abusive
relationship
i
i take the female side but in this case
i'm like but i don't know all the
factors so
everything i say is
doesn't matter
because i know buddy at this table
because i don't know
okay but i haven't followed the case so
but right now i'm like johnny depp you
don't know whatever
well
stop building so many roads
gave up for a cell phone i would have
said about it don't tell me how to play
all right because i won okay yeah keep
building roads [ __ ] hey well i would
say four
as someone who used to beat the [ __ ] out
of my girlfriend
i agree with you heather are you in
danger nah no i'm getting no i could be
the [ __ ] out of that
you could take a punch no i'm not i'm
witnessing uh who wants a break i've
been in i'm gonna be using it right oh i
know weeks
you can't just happy or whatever give me
wheat everything
is clearly like well johnny depp's
really winning public case at least yeah
or making her look horrible
wheat
that would be weak thanks
well yeah everything it's making her
look really bad it sucks yeah but she's
a crazy [ __ ] and she needs to get
checked yeah maybe this will keep her
yeah when you look at like everything
that she came out with this is
definitely an overkill
if she should develop over really bad
she's like a special case of crazy you
know it takes a large amount of like
public backlash it's just funny too that
it's coming out now they're like flashy
[ __ ] elon musk there's a lot of white
ladies
hey they made love yeah
but at the same time like
there's a picture of her and elon musk
together and she has like he has like a
scratched up face it's like oh that's
kind of
peculiar she [ __ ] well that's all it is
and she [ __ ] really well
everything else terribly
her life and again
awesome
is that again yeah i don't think i have
anything
does anybody have a wheat you just get
in the way to hunts
does anybody have a week
does anybody have any
my home five
you can't roll until this time
oh so
that was like eddie
you're like fine it's sick
i saw i had a six and i was like it's
fine it's cool
no it's not a six it's a five
wood
full brick for rock i got it
i don't know
nobody
all right all right we need some wood
get some old son
sorry
why don't i go on your podcast and just
be on my phone the whole time
um
yeah see how you like that see how it
hurts you deep down inside
[Music]
who wants sheep or what
wheat no
rock
rock and wheat
somebody wrote a three i mean
what about rock
for wheat
anyone have wheat you want a rock i want
wheat i don't need rot i have rock i
think you should just pass
out are you going to die
you have one weight
i get i'll give you a you can't trade on
your on my turn you gotta wait till your
turn you wanna rock about that
um rock what about sheep and even
no i need bridge i got to break for you
bro uh you want to rock or one for me
no i need brick
well yeah i don't i can't give it to you
i figured out this game a little bit now
that the [ __ ] i'll give you wood rocks
i'm like sheep for
for a week
okay what i don't need any of you all
right
um i could get brick or something or
sheep i think it break break is more
important but then i guess what are you
doing
or
what is what what cars are you laying
down you don't have no weed over there
like a turning of four rock for one week
four rock for one week you can do that
yes
i'll do that too
[Music]
this is good enough right
this is better does that better sure
um can i do that now oh wait some of my
time yeah you gotta wait till your turn
okay
um sure
always do this you're sure
better i think
okay
sure
okay heather
you're such a [ __ ] four magician's
assistant
yeah i get a word
for oh sheep
yeah it looks like
any brick anybody gonna break
no it just got everywhere
oh wow what are you doing well then
you guys literally
stop and
i already plugged my men below what what
the [ __ ] nice huh
hans is doing fine
he has a house now curtis that's
romantic i live in my car and rob
send me some money like what are you
doing
what you need dude we'll make it happen
right now send me some bread
steady at it
okay you need my venmo don't you know
anything
you're gonna cut it right away this
piece of put your hands up
is that a cool uh is it my terms
slaughter yeah smoke said uh isn't like
four am there sex i'm just found sleep
what you roll six
four
more [ __ ] rock
it's 5 28 here
all right no
we all did shrooms i can't go to sleep
yeah we all did acid and shrooms my
roommate's going to be up soon
you dude
actually what happened to him
i had to sleep i couldn't hear her and
she's
mad
where is she asleep she's in caleb's
room
oh my god shout out to kayla for letting
me use it
is that why he came over here did you
come over here for because i said it was
okay no no yeah he said
who said
well caleb told me to ask clay clay
that it was cool and then i wanted to
happen and then you were like japan i'm
like
yeah yeah dude no but you know what uh
so you just played us
he's he
treated us like shiva
say that again because i started to make
sense when you said shiva you were like
[ __ ] let me ask caleb who was like us
in my bed just like caleb all right i
was not even here i know no he went to
he headed to denver
you know he was like man
jesus christ he got a longest road
six no it's great you uh he's that's i
don't know the whole i don't know why
you were here
yeah we were uh we're going to head back
earlier bro
drunken but we really wanted to play
katan
yeah they wanted to make the south like
overall
no ann's gonna drive us home now we're
all content nor and captain dogs
well she's probably the most well-rested
you should have no guy sure
[Music]
no i do i have three
[Music]
right i got the longest route did you
get anything
seven
seven
okay
dude they're all the same that's
completely what you were gonna get
[Music]
less aggression more uh finesse
the sheep
and rock no
they should just glass
let the knife do the work
it's already done
oh no
maybe let me get a three
eleven
three eleven it's even better it's a
good band
that's my favorite band when i was 12.
how many cars are much supposed to have
less than seven or seven or less you can
have as many as you want [ __ ]
you won last time you know how to play
or play dumb
is the audio okay
luckily the audio
for this one doesn't matter hello hello
i think our podcast that we did was
there was an echo because i think the
video capture device was that had the
mic on
yeah it was exactly yeah i listen to it
anybody need to eat for some brick
wheat for bread
break
i do
we all want to give pizza to all of us
except for one person well give us one
slice to start out with
and let's see who wants more after that
wait can't you development i have to get
on my turn you're developmentally
disabled okay
what uh remember to control
that's
like a nine me with four
roll the four yeah i'm done
patrick do you have any fours
who put it on his three
i did put another number that gets
rolled a lot
same place button minus plus four who's
coming right here let's see if three is
coming no statistics it's very unlikely
that a three would have come
but
was someone picking my numbers up
yeah you got a six
pick up your six
i'm gonna build a road
what did you roll on
boar you don't have any force
hey wait give me one second
that's a good spot
does anybody have a brick they want to
trade me no
nobody wants oh my god
why don't you offer something instead of
asking
calm down
your cutting is not that good
oh my god like you gave the best slice
to his girlfriend
nepotistic thanks man
dude you gave the house a good slice and
that's a little carob
like a peasant oh
[Music]
you need to go back to geometry class
look at this slice
it's a tetrahedron
what what happened man
how did you even get this i couldn't
even make this if i tried it
not too straight lying last week
you got a you cut a pizza with anger
yeah you cut it you cut a pizza like
someone who just lost it and did no no
has the worst [ __ ] pizza ever
is this the joyness
nine
yeah it's the jordan
does anybody have
wood
what you need it for give me some brick
i don't have a brick give me some sheep
or rock i'll take a wheat
i have sheep or rock i'll do it for
wheat
i have sheep or rotten
[Laughter]
this is how the west was won with the
white negotiations
and people like we would take south
dakota and does anybody else i'll give
you a rock
then i will trade in my [ __ ] wood
let's go brandon does anyone does
anybody have a wii god damn it
does anybody ever wait for one
for anything other than
anybody have a weep for rock or sheep
no
i don't do business with pale faces
or you can steal from [ __ ] the guy
who won't round him yeah he's not doing
that well yet i'll watch him eddie has
three points
oh yeah is that a good one no
god damn it
you got shaped i'm not done classic
katan feeling
two three
three
plenty for five
patrick is five
oh heather has four
shoes
the quietest weather has been
you roll oh
five
is that what she says to you
yeah five i'm a tree again
so i think amber heard is just like a
woman out of control and she's hot and
she's able to use society to be like i'm
gonna use what society thinks to get as
much from for me as possible and like
she's a menace she needs to be stopped
yeah white girl would be crazy
white girls be tripping yeah
but i want to smooth though
but yeah i mean she's a powerful force
in nature i wish she would shine in ways
that weren't like
legally troubling actually i didn't even
know she was an actress
she was an aquaman
wait what'd you think she was doing an
aquaman then i know yeah she was she was
the co-star and he thought she was like
an actual mermaid
i'm saying i didn't even know she was in
movies i never heard her before okay no
who else haven't you heard us she's the
girlfriend in pineapple express that's
all i know her from
yeah she's she's suffering a teenager
yeah oh
she's south oregon's girlfriend in
pineapple express she was a good actress
in there right she was yeah
what are you doing oh wait you're
building
save up for a settlement bro
we got all these roads that are going
nowhere
your win with the fluke
you think so 11 yeah
no now they're on do you do we'll see
eleven shiva loss was
hey man i'm killing it compared to the
last game i got like four roads and
man
i ate
[Music]
so ukraine
what are we to do with ukraine
vomit
vomit and the uber your russians price
and the gas prices so there's no gas
breakers
you have [ __ ]
all of you leave the country anyway
sorry there's a lot of women and
children there
didn't they evacuate bomb them who cares
what if america bombed ukraine entirely
yeah they never see that coming and then
when russia what do you want yeah why
don't we yeah what did you just fight
for
war
afghanistan i mean that is true and it's
afghanistan for the last 20 years we've
been [ __ ] middle eastern income
noah's undergraduate
yeah
in the great words of my president joe
biden
sometimes
you gotta just
get on lap dancing hey jack what about
corn pods let dancing and the economy
going up rick no one break no break no
break nope [ __ ]
that's that's what i said cornbop
what are you what are you doing
it's got a corn pop in my shoes
one two three four five six seven eight
six seven
five six
you have way more than seven i have
seven
what's going on here
[Music]
he just finds the line and crosses it
whatever it is
you have to just keep him honest that's
why i can't believe you won
yeah i'm telling you bro i'm just
stubborn
depressing
are you lost something now
hey you know what you're supposed to be
bro
why would you do that i'm not even
winning
like a sheep [ __ ]
that's right do you not eat the crust of
your pizza
[Music]
i'll eat it
you want it
yeah i'll take it i'll take it
no
no
or a sheep
yeah always be closing dude
how are you gonna afford that golden
chain
yeah that was hilarious
oh
jada
fish
so will smith persona non grata amber
heard
douche
beautiful does anybody have a wheat
ellen no
her girlfriend really porsha does
everybody have a week she's gonna scare
her all the time
um
michelle obama
what's wrong with michelle obama she's
[ __ ] great i don't like what she's
doing to schools lunches and stuff what
my kids hate that [ __ ] they should they
hate the obamacare they hate all those
[ __ ] school lunches bro that's the
only thing
no lunches the whole [ __ ]
uh
liberal thing can't wait what are they
eating carrots and celery yeah
basically that's sad man they don't know
they make the meals more nutritious but
it doesn't give them energy kids that
are like starving they're like rabbits
now mm-hmm
that's how terrible it is i like to fall
free lunch up in elementary school yeah
we your kids probably want like you know
wheat cheetos and
anybody for wheat no they're forced to
eat cheetos because they're [ __ ]
garbage ass food that they have or are
we you don't have wheat bring back
greasy burritos
maybe not maybe find a happy medium give
them like
steak
or like a hot dog or oh that'll need
some lamb didn't they get we smoked lamb
they just have no idea they don't they
don't want to fully embrace the
carnivore diet and they don't want to
like
let go of the past seven
country cars up
acting like you know
still i'll still with you if you've been
worried maybe i had eight
thanks for being honest
really
why
she that's unnecessary it's machine feet
[ __ ] you're getting shaped up the
[ __ ]
puns that's funny
thanks you're welcome
how aggressive
um
[Music]
what did you say about my sheep
who cares
yeah what's the point of life anyways
now i like this conversation i can't
believe mars left with her [ __ ] vape
marath
mars mars would not have played kattan
until 5 45 a.m
is it five forty-five
no it's not
you wanted to play another game [ __ ]
all right okay
don't lose energy now
nine
[Music]
wait i need to wait no i need to leave
him yeah you know what that we bro
three metal wood
i need a three wood
roller three
that's what i think
i'm gonna go
puncher
not necessarily
too much
eight
so give me a word
and then on top of that
i'm going what are you picking up wheat
for [ __ ]
are you talking to me yeah
i thought it was eight i'm getting a
little weak oh never mind
that's a wood gonna wood
and uh
you would you can't trade it's heather's
turn you want to drink wood for a week
and uh
eat grapefruit
whatever
that's what's better
so
give me another point
are we done with pizzas already yeah
that pizza was not good it was nothing
not really but i will
i'm going to finish it just to scale
right here
i want some more of that chili pizza
why did robert go to mcdonald's after
this and i'm gonna get a chicken big
your favorite food is the taquito from
santa live yeah yeah
and i love 7-eleven shouldn't miss
myself
it is everything
you're going to chug me
whatever hey are there any funny
7-eleven 911 jokes no
she wants to be one of those ones
well you know
small
i have a joke about inside jobs
inside jobs yeah like air conditioning
no 7-eleven is an inside job
that's so funny hans
why didn't they like my joke about
highway safety
can i hate it um uh i think it was over
their head
i hope so
okay yeah that's not how that happens
well he said now brown guy
oh i did not say that mine
thankfully please will you be so kind as
to let me thankfully please
yes
ew did i do that on camera
[Music]
you should just have sex on camera
they're practically i mean i guess we'll
take your card
who's gonna bend mommy
what are you doing
she's about to
suck me on camera asking for venmo stuff
this is what i'm doing there's something
creative
any wheat more money please
because you've been rolling around again
he rolled the nine like five hours ago
oh i just barely got mine
it blew
[ __ ]
i do not remember now
nine i rolled nine
did you just grab a clog
you guys are all cheaters that's what i
figured out i never cheated i cheated
one time and he commented yeah yeah
that's how that works
i want you to get this
dick hold on i gotta [ __ ] let go of
the cards then he's gonna give you a
sheep all right let me let me go with
this thing you're going to steal one for
me
he's trying to mind check you what he
goes to hand you is a brick but it's
he's going to pretend like it's a shot i
don't even know take what he pretends to
give you
my
is
i never heard it i got it
never i genuinely never had viewers oh
you got your chips on me
sometimes that happens
oh yeah
basin series people oh my god no i'm in
decency these hanzas
well they're just drinking
my alcohol
yeah can i eat it what is this
[Music]
that's not what humans do
they give me
right there i can't believe you're doing
my wheat [ __ ] that was hurtful two
ah i got a wheat
oh i got two
no
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait no wait wait wait wait no no
calm down why are we
dude why do you guys like slurping [ __ ]
because we don't give up
anyone else who lives in this house what
is it it's just weird it doesn't add
anything
it's seven you guys unless you print
this and put it on the blondes
i'm not sure it's
please dude
yeah you won
yeah you gonna share can you pour shots
for all of us
we all do our shots
bring their glasses on what is this
stuff
it's awkward and done done
don't drink it right away that rusted
cherry
i pour shots like a real man jesus
christ
oh my god
all right cheers i didn't want that how
do i have slapped access give me the
arkansas glass right next to you
after what is that
what is that
can you wipe down the
vodka yeah like it's one of this sure
but can you do more than that yeah i
mean i wasn't sure what you're talking
about
cleaning off
i'm [ __ ] sucked
thanks for giving us four
full brims of that thank you roman fours
over there dude that's only benefiting
you fours are
a common thing okay well it didn't
benefit me that much
here
yeah
dude it's your fault
you know what provided i should stay up
yeah
caleb said that to ask clay and then
you said yes
yeah i can actually weep him
yeah
oh hell yeah you guys
can you wake up
from me
[Music]
it doesn't help me at all or
did anybody have me we yummy as patrick
does yummy we waiting to have your
friends
legally smoking marijuana i'll give you
a week for a loving right i want you to
keep doing it the state needs to change
to you and say
joseph
no i can't do it though no all right all
right
what do you think about
jorge mas vidal punching colby covington
in the face
any of the [ __ ] is a bag
well yeah it's unfortunate that he
didn't kill him it's unfortunate he
didn't kill the [ __ ]
everybody was uh on a [ __ ]
who was on his [ __ ] the d.a no one no
one i've ever seen is on his chest
i liked what dana white said which was
hey we all said if that happened to us
we would do it he [ __ ] did it he did
do it so [ __ ] true
some guy i would hate to be in that
position some guy [ __ ] sexually
assaulted his [ __ ] daughter okay you
don't have to say it like that yes
they they don't say it they say don't
say it it's weird to be said
that's what [ __ ] happened to kane
black you already just did
for a second he has to think about the
fact that his three-year-old daughter
was [ __ ] yeah
what a thing to do that he now makes it
a public thing now
and they didn't [ __ ] do anything
because they had no evidence quote
unquote so
oh yeah and bless you guys
the guy who raped cain velasquez's
daughter is free so cain velasquez saw
him he's not straight he's out on three
he's out on bail the deputy not on bail
is ridiculous he raped the king yeah but
he's not free
oh
yeah but he's not free you said
something incorrect
be allowed to be i'm not saying exactly
you showed me what is i'm just saying
he's not free i say that he is why are
you saying
mommy
yeah yeah
yeah you definitely should have raped
children and if you're gonna rape
children try not to do it a hundred
times and also try not to rape the child
of an mma
crazy yeah give her a children be better
wow
take your targets
yeah yeah
this guy did show that if you rape an
mma guy's daughter did you
replace the settlement
okay
number five
thinking now i don't think you really
won last time i just think you put your
roads down and
it was on it's on the floor
you got six points patrick
sick yeah
do you still have it who's white white's
close to it
no you're not i'm getting there buddy
hey family i'm doing it honestly
who wants rock i need wheat
anyone needs raw
wheat i need weed
oh
who wants brick i need wheat
can you not talk during my turn
i need wheat who needs weeds oh my
goodness heather's gotta break down or
what really just
two brick i only have no
i'll give you a wee brick i only have
one i'll give you guys a brick of the
sheep i don't know it's being a little
bit do you guys have right now
do one of you guys have my phone babe no
i don't have your jewel there it is yes
jesus
can i have your jewel after
hans are you done being a little bratty
boy i traded with patrick are you good
not the only one who's in trade with
patrick
okay
five
five
give me wood i hate playing with
americans hey hans
do these i agree green is an auction bro
what's wrong with them
i just i don't know i didn't say
anything was wrong but he take him i'm
so out of way more bravery that's what
he meant
guys than they are
in dallas they're more bless your heart
whites here they tell you [ __ ] it to
your face because they don't they're not
familiar you're not a critical mass to
be able to
stage a revolution no in dallas they
know they'll get slapped or something
yeah why is there something right up
there
here the whites are brazen they're
brazen yeah
there's a [ __ ] uh what is it packing
pad a note
pooty i don't know
kind of patagonia
patagonia vest
and uh
carhartt
and then i played
no i still got a little bit okay
did anybody have all right that's what
you play you're begging
i play beg
does anybody have a break
a brick
for a week for a week
uh i can't i can't mess with the break
okay we i can do a brick
no i got there rock no
rock for a brick nope
two wood for a brick no
three wood for a brick no you do rock
for a weed
a white a rock for a week a whopps a
white a week a what
two sheep for a week
so what do you think about ben shapiro
two sheep for a rock a brick
yeah
think cool i think he's cool just as
much i think
alex jones is cool
[Music]
i mean they say crazy [ __ ] and they're
entertaining
i don't think that they should be
listening to you for policy advice who
was listening to them for poverty advice
a lot of nerds he [ __ ]
hey [ __ ] [ __ ] nobody when we don't
respond that's a
on purpose
stop the thing who wants to give me a
one for two sheep no one two sheep
for two sheep
yeah she's not here
you're not coming to sleep anymore yeah
you're a [ __ ] dude you just did a [ __ ]
thing
so then i prayed for
that
oh my god
and sniper down the bridge explain that
everything she does now
it doesn't mean
goddammit
at least you have five points
hey tom
that was very loud by the way
my nine
yeah you're nine
my nine my nine iron my nine is telling
[Music]
nice pipes
thank
[Music]
i didn't you a brick no
for wheat
what are they saying anything that gives
you endorphins
anybody wants sheep
no
all right
or what
anybody wants brick or wood or wood i
don't have a brick
i have a wood
how is that shot feeling wouldn't you
know it but i don't wait
a while
wait
that's more sheep so what do you think
about
politics
politics is
[Music]
[Music]
but otherwise you have to do but not joe
biden just like in general
yes right there's ideas
yeah but he's like a centrist
center see there's three options
yeah politics okay but you gotta choose
right or left i gotta use right or left
conservatives
or gays
[Laughter]
no
workers rights uh fair payment for fair
work
you know not giving all our money to the
rich uh equal well they're taking the
limit quality we're not giving someone
they're taking it
yeah well we let them take it well
that's because we're a bunch of [ __ ]
we need to stop letting them know
exactly that's what the left stands for
is not being trustees okay but if you
think about it if you're letting them if
people are letting them take it
then i'd rather be the right i mean well
why wouldn't you want to be the people
that aren't letting them because the
right are winning obviously because
they're gonna destroy the planet huh the
plan is already [ __ ] well we cannot
[ __ ] it we can unfuck it maybe we would
be dead by the end
i don't know you know what about your
kids eating obama lunches
they're already going through it they
already [ __ ] us yeah so you're just
gonna be okay with that i'm not okay
with it but
unless you unless you fight for it i'm
not gonna fight for it i'm fighting for
it how are you fighting for it let me
join the fight i'll join i'm fighting
for it by being against the system that
is currently
that does nothing it's doing more than
you're doing what you having babies and
supporting it
out loud that you're against it that
makes you against it but what does it do
that's all i need to do
no but it's one more voice
there's one more there's
well that's all i can control okay
exactly
what do you do with your
bro so what do you do with it
and that's why i gotta answer
do you guys have any wheat you're on the
light
i know i don't i'm not gonna turn it
right i'm not gonna clean the rock i
feel like this is good hold on hold on
hold on hold on
with this
so okay so where are you all what your
voice to be one yes hypothetical one i
mean yeah i'm pretty much one it's
pretty hypothetical they're making out
to the one
definitely left
i always thought left was good but then
less left are the ones complaining about
[ __ ] and yeah and raising taxes so so
you think that things should stay the
same we should stop complaining no no we
can't change the how [ __ ] up it is now
we have to obliv we have to take
everything and start over legalize all
and that's not left or right because
left click on that [ __ ] bro then
it's chaos see your guys was
the table wait what is that
people they're they're if it was 15
acres in the mule 48 characters
yeah we got to help the blacks
are you died
it is funny some dude offered he has i
don't even know somebody who would offer
elon musk 100 acres
and a meal
a mule to open up the uh twitter
headquarters here and it's like yo
that's two black guys and a half that's
two and a half black guys of acres right
there that's a good
sitcom with charlie sheen yeah
that's literally funny it's a reference
to a show that's similarly titled
do you ever see the two and a half
minutes ending oh my god dude no i
haven't seen that
hey
[Music]
oh you're the height of luxury right now
you're just drinking water like you're a
[ __ ]
as you get white
things like like your strength because
it's my water bottle
that's
so weird nailed it
all right anybody need brick no one
needs brick
wood nope no i knew you would
i need brick you don't want rock
you trade that yeah that is
oh one two three four
patrick saw his longest road right right
you're facing three probably four five
six count your roads then there it is
two three four five six i got six seven
eight no no
seven
all right anybody need sheet
nobody she
one two three four five six seven eight
nine did your level six nine i like
this
number
four
like one
he was too late it's your fault
yeah get off at six
patrick
did you take that [ __ ] shot idiot
oh you didn't take the shot you [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
i want to see that on tape
i want to see him be like cheers
why did we do that
that was a lot of
poison no more justice it was terrible
consciously
move the robber
seven
what the [ __ ] was that dude
shut up
that was the worst [ __ ] did we just
drink every [ __ ] uh the paint dinner
and [ __ ]
give me one of your
yeah
cards
no no no don't take that one no no no no
no no no no
let me mix them up
no give me that [ __ ] card i see it go
ahead
thank you
what are you thinking
what is this like
it was my next pillow oh yeah what was
the cook because
where's my road
i broke the wall
[ __ ]
so we'll see let's try so coaching
somebody [ __ ] your wife i'm kidding
um
[Laughter]
yeah it's overworking itself my neck is
overworking itself what does that mean i
don't know do a lot of people wear these
animals because i have a neck a
degenerative neck injury oh yeah
yeah how was that
it was injurious
every single time what did you do what
did you do today every single time
yesterday avoid jujitsu at all
play it here
and give me a second
because i'm about to play
something else no she's about to win
no i'm not oh hello
wait give me one second you win money
wait give me one [ __ ] second
make sure that you being mad make us
wait
calm down hans you don't think about how
we're awake so jealous of how i'm going
to win
you're literally so jealous it's insane
so how much money are you making hey
shut up
like
it's gonna be the new like wig syphilis
wig dude i kind of wear one two
three of them dude
can i bump one
no it's yeah i don't think right
it's like seeing like a ribbed condom
and be like look that's like seven
condoms in one it's just one condom yeah
heather has seven
fortunately i kept up and your points
are accurate eating
i'm not
dude i'm a bitter loser i would have
called her out if she cheated in front
of me no i do not just trust
her actually let's just trespass right
down the car you definitely is gonna be
honest about everything
he [ __ ] you know he [ __ ] yelled
[ __ ] [ __ ] hates you sister
does anybody ever
think
and then
but i literally can't cheat at all
oops
that's
[Music]
i really don't trust any of you i think
you build settlements you're not
building anything but roads
i want to save up we got to save up for
wheat by not building three um pointless
roads
two pointless roads
okay are you done here
perfect
i'll be honest i should not have been
used to this thing
yeah it's called the desert yeah
figure that one out
[Music]
that's my people
well yeah you love deserts
you love spicy deserts
no please do not
i have it because it's an injury and
you're asking me if you can punch my
injury
he's just saying
but we're tied yeah so do you still get
the two points so we tied yeah
okay winner or a home field advantage
etc etc
are you off that wheat pen yeah
or this [ __ ] maybe alcohol y'all made
me drink it's called drunk
you think so
yeah
one second english
the louder the better
no can you talk three seven can you talk
a little bit
yeah we want to
just a little bit just a dialogue switch
it up
uh
how i met your mother korean how i met
your mother in korean
she rolled a seven does anyone else have
what do you give
one two three four five six
two one three four five six seven five
seven eight and ten
six
so you can have eight points but you
have six right now
shiva's standing strong at two
right now i seen him pulling a lot of
cards while you're going
i
wait let me i got i haven't traded but i
have to i got in here
the seven [ __ ] me up a little bit
the seven might have [ __ ] me honestly
i don't even know what the [ __ ] you two
are doing like yeah it's this
you guys
they're really trying to win shiva
that's what's happening they're trying
to win again
wait give me one second what
so shiva um
hey what's your instagram
uh for the people
there's no people
they're asleep already
brad said shiva translates to shitty
accutane
yeah oh my [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
that one my instagram is packard
you want to go look up patrick topari on
instagram i have a couple or on youtube
i have a couple of rose videos on there
that are pretty fun
yeah just three rows battles that are
really funny and then i have a set that
i did on eight tabs of acid that's
really funny nice what's 18 divided by
two
nine nine nine
oh you're like you reach your all-time
high you come on roads now
i don't believe any of your roads are
authentic
why i don't know
something so that's why i hated them all
roads i mean
wait
[Music]
this is uh a lot better game when i'm
not true
are you getting shrimp do you want some
mushrooms
can i have some shrimps i only have like
oh my gosh
oh [ __ ] wait a minute we can't
that's fake it's satirical we're banking
around
the whole yeah
drunk or high on anything we're all
[ __ ] around the whole foods
dude i love those like big mushrooms
from whole foods the one you can stuff
with like spinach dip on farms
yeah we just bought some like big ass
shrooms and stuffed them with spinach
dip and like breadcrumbs and [ __ ]
recently it was pretty
brand just called somebody a pussyhound
i don't know who though
okay one two three four five six wait
who has the longest road
one two three four four six seven
look at khan's flexing bro
yeah bruh oh goodness he he brought the
spa to the podcast
what the [ __ ] is that like the most
common most probable number to be ruled
or what
[Music]
can i use it
after i'm done relieving my pain
well
that's super convenient for me
i'm gonna trade in my other little uh
tool attachment uh-huh
want to trade
along with that yeah
okay they're good
that's what the chair works
i like that more than the neck of it
i prefer the next thing i feel like
gives you more relief than the
neck pillow thanks anyway thanks for the
info i'll let my body now
wait did someone steal from me no how
much is this
it's like a hundred bucks really
what are you showing us that for [ __ ]
lay your hand
one two three four five six seven eight
nine you got nine do you have a victory
point
he does
play your [ __ ] homie three four five
let's go to sleep
ain't no victory point
you got nine right off and winning
is there how many minutes are close to
women yes three four five six seven
people [ __ ]
shut up
we're leaving
wait do you have longest road one two
three four no i got seven two three four
five six seven he's the winner ty goes
to the one who had it
the belt holder
there you go bro yes the rules are the
rules girl the rules dude
not everything is right or left
you just said it was
left right you got to pick one like if
he's game left to right this game is not
a person this game is an object well
just okay so the way this the way we've
been like making our own roads and
training
is that communism well you need the
workers to build the roads this is a
third world country
well i don't think people should be
right or left i think people should be
people and and why are you putting on
category
because i want to know what you think
about [ __ ]
really don't well you don't have to you
got it everyone is supposed to know
everything yeah i'm a people bro you're
supposed to be good on your part
so whatever you're doing i'm putting my
part
it's just like
people doing their part is helpful to
the system
yeah it's helpful to my system my kids
system my family system
that's my sister my family is my sister
the family that you created for no
reason
not my family the family that created me
too
yeah yeah
yeah they all got a circle that's
important that's like the main use of a
person is to help the people around you
but then if you start extrapolating to
the family and then
like okay
uh i carry around these neutral grain
bars i try to give it to them every
chance i get i give them money can i get
one no
no you won already you have to do the
other victory from katan
but what can i actually do to help i'm
what you know
i like to have a system that helps them
right
i don't i mean look whether you do
something for them or not i still think
that you're doing enough
yeah you got to do whatever you can yeah
it's just not good podcasting
oh my god hans
well you can't i you can't just do
whatever you want
every time any time anything happens
what do i want to do that's the easiest
to do
um but yeah i mean i uh what what do you
what do you think that we should do for
the homeless how would you oh yes
i mean i don't have no knowledge and
yeah we're going to be responsible for
it
where's my i mean
we actually i do like to
say man i don't wear trillions of
dollars in debt instead of helping
another country we should help fix this
country first
yeah but that doesn't help the rich
that doesn't help the rich yeah they
they rather go to another country and
track wall street man oh no i know
what would you do if you were them
i would pay people fairly for the work
they do instead of paying them a minimum
wage i would pay them for the work that
they actually do
that's what you're too graphic i would
how would that keep you rich though i
wouldn't be rich i would the society
would be rich so sorry
man thanks for coming
yeah thanks for having me no one is
happy unless you're too many
but there's so many more people
that
can
help than the people that need help
yeah man
care i do care about the community
donated uh 800 million dollars to
ukraine
military defenses
that makes sense to us that's sexy we
like sending guns
the fact that they send all of that
money on just a whim of life that's what
they say man
right exactly i believe
is that
like five points two billion or whatever
that went there's always corruption
we should at least try to spend money
you see how chris was uh about boredom i
was driving a mad yeah i mean that's
what society is going to just being
bored and being done and want to kiss
himself for it yeah it's not uh
it's easy to combat
it's easy to be like oh i might be bored
but let's actually like figure things
out yeah it means like if my kids say
i'm bored i'd be like that that i don't
care about that you better figure it out
because you know nothing's changing
because you're bored i'm not going to
lift a finger because someone's bored
well we have a society that dulls us
into complacency
it gives us no outlet it doesn't want
you to be creative it wants you to be a
cog and who wants to keep using you so
boredom is a tool that they use they
want you to be bored yeah i think having
fun and seeking novelty and thrills is a
good way to live your life yeah i mean
if you're a type of dude that can kind
of plan out bye
like come up with a plan and actually do
some effort to achieve it then you know
there's still a lot of distractions out
there for the week you know
yeah
that's what i mean
does she say it's morning and early
morning yeah it's
6 30 yeah we'll probably head out of
here like around 11 30 12 o'clock though
we have a couple hours of sleep and then
yeah but we all care about what's
happening to our society around us i
think so i mean i care about my
community yeah and if you think about
what's best for the community it
eventually turns into communism
oh communism is the answer then that's
what you're saying well it's gonna feel
like communism what
communism i think it
it sounds so negative in america those
are
itself like it sounds like communities
yeah the word movie more south
korean karl marx probably yeah karl marx
but i mean helping the society yeah
because capitalism
happened
by the way
so we should just rape no we should just
lean into raping no we should try not to
rape right
that's communism which is lincoln
yeah
no yeah capitalism is like there's your
guys into race
i mean god then communism is just like
not giving a [ __ ]
right nobody you know read the terms we
care about each other do you ever regret
terms and then you know the
community is important and a little bit
more even capitalism yeah in terms of
conditions of a nap or something yeah i
never rate it i mean that's kind of
raping us right
well with capitalism you get rich and
you use your riches to get richer and to
help yourself get richer and make it
harder for other people to get rich and
if you don't then other people get
richer than you and make it harder for
you to get rich so then eventually one
person has everything and everyone else
does not know
25 years it doesn't work right when has
it or maybe five years now that's where
we've working with prevalent but why did
communism fail usually because america
invaded the country and made sure it
failed or i cannot yeah yeah i'm gonna
get that but yeah
i mean just because russia went from
world war ii where they lost like
a hundred
so what is that so what do they say to
be in the space race what's the
sacrament is this communism people work
the main argument against communism is
that we can kill you if you try
and we are
violent and vicious like even capitalist
americans
now there's i mean i think that's
changed
over the years compared to like i mean
in like the 50s and stuff red scare kind
of [ __ ] like yeah it was that i don't
know if it yeah
it's all like well socialism lost and
now we can't believe this is more
capitalist we're just the whole
capitalistic world
and now look at how we feel and look at
where we are like none of these problems
are because of communism
that we have it's because of capitalism
yeah yeah i feel like i you know you
kind of make any sense you're making
sense but i feel like i should argue
with you because you're asian and i'm
representing for americans right now
asian i'm american too well yeah but it
seems like you're pushing communism and
you know my country and this is a red
state bro like communism
and i just don't think you're good i'm
just talking about taking care of your
community honest in a smart way and
that's called communism yeah
well you don't have to call it you can
you can still do that in the capitalists
how would you do that just doing it you
can actually take care of community in
this i think the where does the money
come from
so you tax people no it comes from your
[ __ ] you aren't you
that's what we're doing now it's not
working we're like everyone these are
people giving their money away to the
communities yeah when they should
but they're not with your taxes on
change you if you have the money you
just go ahead and do it like you don't
need anybody
the only way that you get that money is
by being greedy if you're not greedy
then you lose that money
greedy just to take care of your company
and then you stop being greedy at a
certain point
i mean that's like antithetical to their
mindset and then once you stop being
greedy you'd be overtaken by someone who
is who would be greedy yeah right i mean
it's drug dealing
it's just a fight to the bottom yeah
yeah at some point we got to be still
thinking
too from that right i'm not saying we
shouldn't lean into the
now competition we should try to not be
are you saying jordan peterson is wrong
for what he said disagree with jordan
peterson yeah you said it never worked
communism never worked he said it never
worked and then yeah
that capitalism is the only way that it
worked it's been working but it's just a
lot of greedy i think it's a rule that's
destroyed capitalism is there like
that's just like you know it's like an
opening day give it as fair shot we
weren't like okay let's see if communism
works let's see
[Music]
look at the police force or the fire
department or the trash collection or
like
health care in other countries
in in this country right now they're
they're they got a career they got a
yeah that could be all of us we could
have a career doing whatever we do we
have enough money it's just all going to
the wrong areas they keep telling us
that we're in debt so we won't be asking
for no money what would this country
look like if we weren't in debt well did
they have to hand me up right
yeah but they keep telling us that we're
we're broke that's why they're not
[ __ ] giving us [ __ ]
yeah i mean we didn't get everybody else
they want to have a system where it's a
plantation
yeah or where this like if you owe 32
trillion dollars what do you think the
next bank is going to tell you when you
ask for a loan what are they going to
tell you
they're going to say go to [ __ ] hell
yeah they won't put five dollars
if you know uh
why are we still [ __ ] giving away
money we don't have money
yeah yeah we want to get willing to
clear that debt and that way we can take
care of this country and how how can we
do that no one's talking about that we
got to give the working class more money
we gotta have instead of that's how the
economy functions if one guy has 500
trillion dollars he's only going to need
one pillow but
500 000 people have that money that's
500 000 pills
there was like 45 years ago there was a
saying uh the the richest man was like
maybe four billion dollars
it was a couple billionaires now it's
like 400 something billion yeah but but
nothing in 25 years the minimum wage is
still the same yeah yeah the cost
productivity goes up yeah so that's the
biggest thing economics but they want to
make it about transgenders and you know
getting to use the bathroom whichever
way they're pretty argued about that
they're just really the media doing that
yeah they're not really real people yeah
the media is not real people
it's people that don't want to make the
sacrifice like liberals that want to be
like yeah we support it all but then
they're like uh you can't have
single-family housing you gotta pay more
in taxes like we don't really want let's
i'm more about the transgender thing
who's voting for these things too like
you know like is anybody like actually
voting to be taxed more i don't think
anybody's voting for that at all period
yeah i mean i know uh it's just
happening
joe rogan said on his podcast that he
doesn't mind being taxed right it's like
i'm fine yeah i paid half and time 100
or something
spotify out
yeah i'll be my fair share
i'll pick my fair share because like i'm
good with one million he got over 100
you know i can make one million just the
way that money trickles
into our economy doesn't mean it's fair
right it's
like
it's roughly efficient but there could
be more corrections and we could fix it
and make it a better society overall but
why do you think they don't want to fix
it i think they're joking
it's good though like you
he's like real person and like right you
gotta buzz by twitter you should just
fix the [ __ ] homeless problem
it's what he are you finding
okay so is that gently is that
conservative
is that right or leg he just did he took
care of me he's an artist he's spending
money whatever way he pleases see that's
what i'm talking about dude what you
want baby in america you can do that you
can buy twitter yeah and buy twitter in
american cat i don't like that but he's
not doing that
i mean
is that like the best way you're batting
him for whatever the [ __ ] he's doing
this is what america is like people got
the right to [ __ ] yeah
playground for the rich
slaves and then like the rich get to do
whatever they want with us
it's okay i'm going to be rich one day
but i
would never be a slave i i know that
like mentality wise i can be poor but
i'm okay with being poor i don't think
you're [ __ ] either way we're all
about someone like there's only one
richest person in the world so and why
do we like we're going to change society
starbucks and we don't charge them like
a million dollars for coffee
like you know what i'm saying
there's no way taxes you know i'm
talking about him just like let's say
you worked at starbucks and jeff was
just walking a million
yeah for real
if you don't want to get out that's the
nature of the people like they are
they're out of mercy we they're that
rich because we let them be yeah we need
to over we need to charge them extra
because we know they got it
yeah they're not happy
uh sure what okay
yeah judge everything through that lens
no but i'm well he's going like extreme
if i'm selling lemonade yeah and jeff
bezos
it's a dollar but for you it's two
million dollars
if you don't want to keep running back
hit the road jeff bezos
yeah but when workers if we all do that
then that's called unionization and this
is we could do more
rich people do whatever they want like
we have to use our power we can't just
be like yeah we should just not
collectively bargain we should just
unionize everything
the people there can be an
i've just noticed the people that
usually fight for power usually then
just abuse their power it's just so you
know there's not always there's
ways they can use thousands of words
wording to make it law that doesn't mean
we shouldn't try
oh we should not pursue power because it
always leads to corruption i think
foreign
i feel like we should just die our best
lives well why don't you try to not be
corrupt like just do like try to get
power and then also try to temper
yourself
and do both that's what i'm talking
about like being greedy and actually
helping your community just for that
purpose yeah yeah yeah i mean
we always have to do both yeah but well
i feel like
in terms of
like a [ __ ]
thanksgiving that doesn't really work
when we're just like we're just gonna be
greedy as possible and then try to be
nice at the end of it yeah this is the
result of that yeah
we need a little more niceness i think
instead of more meanness but what does
this sound like does this sound like
it's uh it's a possibility i don't think
that it's like inevitability that's like
there's no other way this works that's a
[ __ ] uh i mean sometimes
i get that like we went to the moon like
we can't be nicer we went to the moon
we invented smartphones and we can't be
a little nicer to each other i mean we
didn't go together it was the
smartphones is to avoid being nice to
people like the smartphone is still good
people unfortunately ubereats that's to
avoid people
right
stay at home just avoid everybody
yeah you can get everything but then
everything else is for people
like there's no reason why we do any of
this especially comedians
we're talking to them at an emotional
level but even if you're not like
rappers or anyone who wants to be
successful or is driven is driven by
their love of humanity okay since we're
on the subject what do you think about
tv
hi
i'm saying great more people doing it
did you watch any clips of uh what's
been going on with tf
dude you haven't seen anything ti comedy
related
well there was a comedian running the
show and t.i was there and she brought
up some accusations that he did and he
got upset because it was in atlanta you
know atlanta his city he a rapper you
know it's a city he got up on stage just
snatched that mic from her bro and then
started like hold up hold up don't be
saying that [ __ ] about me cuz you
know it's an accusation yeah trying to
make me sound guilty blah blah blah and
then she got to my back she was like
well this is my comedy show
he got mad again exciting
dude it was crazy and he got booed out
of the ring
what happened at an arena
comedy shows now well why did they show
up to his show and they knew him it was
skipper godfrey doing the show oh and
then and then t.i showed up like hey
he died
not giving godfrey that's what i'm sorry
uh it's uh
freeman doctors
godfrey is not doing arenas yeah
he did an arena godfrey
yeah the guy that does impressions or
even now michael winslow
godfrey
he does like uh he does like gilbert
died yeah kill a gun
uh he looks like denzel
yeah
godfrey sure so he went up before
godfrey and then he went up he asked him
to go after him after he finished
headlining his show
see how i got off to you and then he did
and then i they were blowing them
afterwards and i would do them too i was
just saw what i wanted to see
and now you're making me stick around
well yeah i mean i think um
you know it's fine he's just like
playing open mic at a bigger venue he's
got a megaphone and now he's like his
mistakes are magnified and if he can
handle that [ __ ]
then welcome to the life you need to
watch the video
i don't think he's handling very well
well yeah he's probably not this is this
is probably going to be practicing
what what do you think about
congregation man's anti-rapper
like
yeah there's a lot of pride authenticity
yeah i mean it's a completely different
art form and they like to think that
they're doing what we're doing but
they're not
and it's more lucrative and financially
rewarding to lie and be like i'm awesome
and i'm the best but i don't know i'm
not easier if you're like
being honest to live in the real world
um and it's more enriching i think or
more uh you know better for people
overall
as opposed to like indulging their
fantasies to like [ __ ] be like this
is how i'm living life and like you know
like the way i do this [ __ ] yeah i'm
better than everybody was just you know
that's not yeah
yeah he's the cream molly cream homie
he got his top there back then
what's going to sing what's ti's ti
songs yeah the timberlake thing like
yeah yeah
that's it
and he rides 24s with the chopper in the
back
oh he also did rubber band man right i
don't know he's the rubber band man
ellie was the the band-aid bands
and uh all the bands
yeah he's tapping into our culture at a
very uh utilitarian level
like uh household office supplies i saw
the the roast that he was on with david
lucas that show they do roast me yeah t
i always yeah i
if they can if he can hang then he's
like a part of the thing then
it seems like he can hang on the rose
part
but uh the stand-up part
like like if he's in a group setting
with five other people and they're
trying to roast them he would like you
better [ __ ] your way uh
shut your ball here looking ass you know
or some [ __ ]
it's like it's that that looking ass
roast you know yeah you better get your
pineapple here looking ass
you know looking like haha looking ass
but you know yeah
it's like it's a format yeah
i think it still works because you still
have to come up with an observation that
sticks
like you look like you drive a hyundai
looking ass
um but yeah i mean i think
try it it's fun to see him fail to be
like oh this is what happens to someone
with too much ego that's fun to see he's
just mad that he's not doing good too he
takes it down to everybody else that's
fun to see it is pretty fun
i'm surprised nobody is content people
love a lot of people ain't talking about
this i have no yeah i don't i'm not
familiar maybe it's because you know
it's it's
a good video it's a good way to watch
the way he was like talking to that
woman
on that comedy set he was talking to her
like she was supposed to be one of his
[ __ ] and she need to respect who he
is
in atlanta yeah because that's his this
is he's just trying to use his turf or
like
that he snatched that mic from her too
like he's like aggressively a little
like kind of assault to me you know if i
was a karen but
he snatched that mic pretty hard and it
was her show it was her show did she
know he was there
yeah because she started roasting him
you just talking about t.i yeah
and uh was he on the show no he wasn't
on the show why was he there
he just checking the police out he's
like look ti's in the audience she's
fine i mean she watched everybody
but it's that kind of comic that hears
about just shows up to try to get on to
use his name to get on she he don't know
nobody though like hey you can put me on
t-shirt
but she started roasting them and then
he just got up on stage and did his own
thing yeah i mean uh if you roast
someone like
you like that's assault in like a
verbal way and it's not like you should
physically assault them back but it's
not like you're not doing anything to
them and they're going to get their
feelings hurt and so that asks you
something to talk about do you think
words hurt too awards definitely yeah
no i would say stand up is you ever
heard the stand up is like a verbal
jesus sticks this smells like way more
honestly
but i think physical violence there's a
limit to it but with mental and
emotional violence it's like it's way
worse sometimes
if you're gonna do it right to a weak
mind though right
well everyone's always no you think so
yeah
not everyone's you shouldn't just try to
be strong no jokes
you should try to like create something
instead of just having a tough
turtle shell you know being tough is a
bad thing too being tough is a good
thing to a degree but not to the
exclusion of your sensitivity so we feel
that word hurt yeah we shouldn't
do it yeah i do agree with that but then
i think understandable i'm saying like
if you had a choice would you wanted to
hurt or not if it didn't hurt we
couldn't do what we did if there was no
risk or danger to it it's like going
down
right to the uh to to like [ __ ] you
know like if
if there wasn't the risk of like
emotional damage or like impact if our
words had no impact then we wouldn't be
able to have an impact with our words
the fact that we can hurt people we
never used to actually talk with words
now it's more of a theme because i think
that that's what that internet created
yeah our ideas are powerful and we
should respect them more
and our words are hurtful but
everybody's ideas like like your friend
uh
yeah she's a one person she gets her
little you know
ballot cast and she gets to do whatever
she wants if i answer did you ever
answer the day i told her
are you mad at her yeah i'm mad at her
because she's emotionally needy because
she doesn't contribute anything she
wants to control the conversation and
doesn't she put me poorly on them
before
well i hate that [ __ ] when i run an open
mic it's all random
i don't want any favoritism yeah that's
what he's constantly i think you just
saw well dean dean put me on here on to
close out one of his shows before the
mic nice that was pretty cool
yeah dude it was fun whooping that ass
on yucatan or katan
sucka man
yeah you want to end this
oh yeah hey guys uh thank you for tuning
in here with hans kim i'm eddie trevino
this is shiva
you guys are gonna be winning for the
first time one of one and then losing
remember the second time i lost the
second first time losing i think they
all cheated was the luck of the draw you
know they got caught cheating
with you
now
look what i got guys the [ __ ] victory
point anyways
thank you for tuning in and tune in next
time whatever hans kim invites his crazy
as austin friends to come play let's
hang out oh yeah